I'm not lying because I thought we were setting things up
because Monopoly, because Monopoly is one of the most like
unoptimized game because it's Ubisoft.
Anyway, anyway, Ubisoft, if you want to Ubisoft, if you want
to sponsor me, I won't shit talk Monopoly.
Anyway, but yes, I am.
but like even not play plus is known to be like the most key
the most like fucked up like optimization because this
online servers fucking sucks so that's why i thought we were
setting up before stream because it's gonna we i don't know
how this is gonna work
credit back me up is she a professional uh one time she
streamed a closet so yeah that's true and i came out oh yeah
see what i don't think i don't think like being proud about
streaming in the closet is like a good thing no it is it is
it's my harry potter origin story vulture came out of my
having room and you ripped off my nose and i said wow you
sure need that buddy and then he cursed me and put a scar on
my head and to this day i've never been the same oh okay i
need i need somebody else to like back me up on this
regarding it to like rain in the affiliate make a point out
of me you have to make a point out of me what is nothing
murder scene okay all right anyway okay phillian host the
game phillian i want to i want to talk first we have things
to go over this out and talk at the same time because at
this rate the whole thing is gonna take like one hour of a
fucking tech support let me just apologize to you okay okay
so i said a word that started with c and i wanted to tell
you i completely take it back that's it that's all i wanted
to say so wait what there was a there's a soft drink that's
really popular and i want to apologize for even mentioning
it i just want to take it back and i'm sorry oh okay okay
thank you thank you okay Okay, I don't know the lore the
lore is too deep the lore is too deep.
I got to y'all that bro.
Shoot Filly what no, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'll try to start the game.
What?
Okay, oh, oh, do you want?
Never mind.
Okay, fine.
I'll start the game dude.
God dang it.
Yeah, I just see you on your twitch stats right now.
I don't I don't see the monopoly game at all.
Why are you stalking me?
What do you mean?
It's because we were like, we're as Philly and she's out
here being like, the collab starts at three.
I don't know why these girls are here early.
What is she?
What are they doing?
And then like, me and Lumi and Pippa were just like, what
the fuck?
And then I had to copy and paste literally a chat message
from Philly and be like, hey, how does like 230 sound?
Or I'll just like, yeah, 230 sounds great.
But it's our fault that we came at 230.
Give me a deeper voice.
All right.
I'm powerful.
He's like, what are these girls doing coming here like 30
minutes early?
What the fuck's wrong with them?
Okay, we're just like, what the fuck is wrong with her?
Dude, the last time someone came early, I got conceived.
Okay, I'm just not used to it.
Let me, let me, I'm starting the game.
I'm starting the game.
I'm free, I'm free, free.
Okay, so I want to leave my lobby code.
That's the important thing, right?
I don't think there is a lobby code.
I think it's just invite.
Private lobby with a code.
Is it private lobby with code?
I don't know.
I just, like, looked at the hosting.
I know, like, a parent Pip-Bit can't host because she has,
like, issues.
I mean, like, not that type of issues, but, like, the NAT
code.
What do you mean by that, Jokey?
What do you mean by this?
I'm just trying to, like, be specific so people be like,
what kind of issues does she have?
I'm like, no, I meant tech issues.
I don't mean anything else.
I think I should be able to host two, maybe.
what am i leaking oh what okay remote play together are we
actually doing remote play for the remote i don't know
someone putting a thing in there what do you think do we do
well like uh yeah that's that's what i'm that's what i said
yesterday i said this yesterday i'm learning it was like
don't worry we can do online and Now you're reading this
week.
I was like, hey guys, people in my chat yesterday were
talking, like, we're talking about we should do like the
remote play.
I'm on Monopoly right now, Kitten.
Give me one sec.
One person buys a game, person who bought the game launches
it and sends a request for a remote play.
So we should all be Steam friends.
We should all be Steam friends.
Okay.
Everybody drop me on Steam friends.
Yeah, I invited, I added everybody on Steam.
So I'll be using the chat.
Okay.
So I play Monopoly.
do i do i go local mode uh well what did that person say it
says remote well i guess it has to be local mode if it's
remote play yeah create a local game not online exactly
you're still right we don't want to try the online at all oh
no we're just gonna crash later on because like most likely
like when you crash they sell off all your property and
stuff to everybody else what yeah so like you know okay well
then what then we just have to not buy it from the ai it's
fine like just don't just don't leave my junk today eyes
fine okay so how do i invite you guys steam there should be
a remote play together button like in the actual game or in
the steam friends list oh in the steam friends list okay
perfect yeah don't worry i'll go online just for you guys
yes please please please so okay so i don't know if i'm
friends with doki that's important wait are we do we not do
a game oh we're We didn't do a game.
I played my Steam code.
We played a VR chat.
It was really different.
Or we didn't even play VR chat.
You were just there.
I was just there.
Like, you just showed up.
I was like, hey, I'm feeling.
I was like, yeah.
I'm feeling
it.
So do I draw my friend code in the chat?
Is that the play?
I put my friend code already.
It's, you scroll up.
Okay.
Did you know that someone's friend code is actually a
portion of their actual account ID, which means you can find
it even if you're not?
Oh, we post it too.
just in case okay i will add you as a friend how do i how do
i do i can't clear anything because so many people added me
i shouldn't have done that okay we should just add you no i
got this okay maybe okay maybe not uh my steam is not going
to the friends okay i'm gonna close maybe we should add you
okay so so we have an issue my steam is not letting me go to
my friend section just refresh it refresh it refresh how do
you refresh steam f5 bro just just bro just crash me bro
just give us your friend code it's easier well i don't know
how to give you my friend code if i can't even go to the
friend section oh yeah okay f5 is not working your honor do
i hit alt f5 oh no no f5 f5 just hit the button you can do
it I pressed it!
Ah!
A few friends lists, that works.
Add a friend.
Oh, okay.
Dude, I'm stuck.
Like a bug.
How are you...
How are you stuck?
Okay.
Wait, can I get to my friends list from my...
Okay, friends.
Oh, wait, wait.
I'm on the way, I think.
I just have to figure out how to get to my friends list a
different way.
So that's pretty easy, I think.
I can just go to...
Oh, wait.
You can just go in the top and hit Add a friend too.
Yeah, that's what I'm trying to do.
But the thing is like if I press the button it doesn't
change my steam It's letting me go anywhere, but the actual
place we need to go.
I'm so sorry How is this browser?
Use the browser use the browser go to the browser.
Okay at the side of my browser now You can look at your
friend code in browser just okay docks it Okay, so can I
look at my okay, so how do I?
Can I copy my profile and then you guys can dox my friend
code?
Wait, what?
none of us is showing our steam what do you mean billion
okay do i restart steam just why don't you just go on the
browser no okay okay i'm logging on my browser okay okay i
don't know fine geez okay fine steam login all right okay i
can imagine pippa just muting just flaming me right now dude
okay i'm not muted are you flaming me though want me to
flame you open i mean just yeah you're gonna publicly at
this a little bit more comfortable i'm having anxiety heavy
breathing just do some insults okay i signed in oh i could
probably just add friends from here isn't that crazy yeah i
remember when i said like why don't you just turn on the
browser no that'd be crazy okay so i went to it's telling me
to sign what okay okay okay wait so how do i Okay, on
browser.
Sign in to add friends.
Come on.
Okay, come on.
Okay, okay.
Hurry.
Okay, okay, no, but like, okay.
So I'm on the browser, right?
Okay, I'm on the browser, right?
Yeah.
Okay, there is no panel that says friends.
You can look at your scene code.
How?
I can host it.
I've got it.
How about I host it?
Okay, fine.
You host it.
Whatever, man.
Okay, okay.
Can I just open a custom game or create game?
Just create a game.
Do a local game.
Local, go to local, create a game.
And then...
I'm getting real poised.
I won television.
Freak me.
Local?
Local.
You can't come here.
Well, you can't play local.
I made this business.
Just get public and private.
Private, private, private.
Just do private.
Okay, okay, private.
Okay, private.
Living board?
Classic board?
Oh, living board.
Do living, do living, do living.
do living like wait you don't have a third option no i have
a third option we can have rabbit mode the game session will
automatically start in five minutes yeah yeah no it does
that yeah i saw that too okay let me in wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait if i hosted i have the rabbit board
oh i have to add you to ubisoft that's what i'm saying
mother wait no no no we don't have to we're doing remote i'm
an epic failure no no i'm an epic failure oh wait wait wait
guys Like this is gonna be a lot of technical issue No, no,
no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
I was cooking.
We're all played together.
None of you believe that when I trusted Philly.
None of you.
Why did you trust Philly and over me?
I am trustworthy.
Watch out.
I was not online.
Okay, Token.
I added you as a friend.
Guess what?
I got there.
Hipple, get online.
They said it could have been done, but I didn't.
That is like the lowest point.
benchmark you can have yeah but i'm on the board baby yeah
that's just like passing it's like getting a 50 and being
happy about it i'm gonna have a degree and you're gonna be
having single freak you all right so now i'm here i invited
all right i'm in the remote play i invited everyone i think
i'm in i'm in wait how you have to make sure you make
another make another uh slot for us because like we're
remote play so yeah we need another slot oh i don't know but
i'm controlling your mouse right now i can't click on any of
these things okay i'm in i'm in click on Okay, okay.
Yes, right.
I got this.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, kiddos.
The present they're putting together friends want to play.
Make sure the host enables the keyboard and mouse controls
to the friend.
Oh, okay, okay.
Enable me.
Yeah.
So one person has to use the controller.
I'll plug in the controller.
Okay, okay.
I'll use the keyboard because I'm gonna have to keep my
keyboard.
Okay, I gave you all stuff, but- Pippa, your internet's not
working?
Now how do I add more people?
How do you add more people?
How do I add more people?
The game's going to start a token.
Look at the instructions.
Where are the instructions?
The instructions.
Why don't we just play online?
Instructions.
Billion.
Okay.
It says make sure the host enables a keyboard and mouse
controls to the friends.
That's what it says.
I gave it.
And then what?
That's what the mask is.
Uh.
Oh, that's something that says invite player.
Maybe just like re-invite us.
in though i can only invite the ubisoft no like because
we're oh wait what the what oh someone hit a b button
because it's me awesome i see someone that's me that's me
are you i think you're in online you're in online you're not
local i'm going back go back go back you're so brain damage
Yes, you're in online mode!
Chat, are we stupid?
Let us know in the comments section.
Look at my screen.
Back out.
Back out again.
Low call.
So how many VTubers it takes?
Can you just do it for me?
I think the more VTubers you have, the longer it takes.
I'm gonna say that right now.
You have to not do rabbits!
Bro, we should do rabbits mode!
Do rabbits mode!
Rabbits!
Do it for Pippa!
Bro, we should do rabbit's mode.
Oh, bad.
Is that rabbits?
Is that rabbits mode?
Now, can you join?
I picked rabbits mode.
This is local, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Did you enable keyboard for us?
Yeah, did you enable?
Let me check.
Can you enable us?
I fucking enabled you.
I'm taking it away from you right now.
I see you.
I see you use that, too.
Give me my rights.
I gave you your rights.
You don't deserve any women.
Like, what?
I'm on!
Okay.
Alright, so how do we...
Okay, so your guy who gave you your instructions, how do we
make a new person?
He just says...
Oh, I got one!
One person buys a game.
Oh, my God.
Someone's getting that one.
Okay, okay.
And then...
Then, Lumi, add two more.
Add two more, Lumi, add two more.
One of them has to be controller.
Yes!
Okay, we got this.
How do we swap the controller?
How do we swap that?
One of them has to be on controller.
Pick something!
That's not me!
Wait, am I controlling this?
Oh, this is me!
I'm player three!
Who wears me?
You have a place, nerd.
Wait, is Pippa in here?
You gotta, you gotta, you gotta select your thing.
Oh, you turned me into an AI!
You effing NPC applied me!
Wait, how do we turn?
Well, the AI will do more work than the original, so I- No,
that's not true.
I'm wearing a weapon world of worship.
The AI will definitely win the game.
Okay.
Lumi, you're the top hat.
Is anyone getting game sound from this?
Because I'm not.
I have game sound.
I have- I don't- I don't hear anything in the game.
I don't hear game sound either.
Yeah.
I hear game sound either.
Is that what I mean?
Does your guy know how to fix game sound?
What the fuck?
It was literally an ingress screenshot.
It's my bacon!
Motherfucker!
Oh my god!
Stop moving my mouth.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
I'm gonna rip someone's hair out.
It could be mine.
I don't know.
Wait, you guys can hear it.
I can't hear the game sound.
I invited you.
We're all remoting.
All remoting.
Okay.
How do we make this not an AI?
It's not an AI.
Pick a thingy.
Okay, Chad, can you hear the music?
No, I don't.
You guys, my child's like, I hear it's just really faint.
And I'm like, you hear music?
I barely hear it.
I don't hear anything.
let me hear you don't hear anything wait wait wait wait wait
i can hear the game which is really quiet you guys can it's
really quiet do you want me to turn it up oh my god it's so
quiet oh i hear it i have to turn up my volume you close the
game what join again okay wait we're still four players four
player in here i think pebble's connection is literally
dropping so often you can't even join okay is gonna be
people and then we're gonna put player four as dogee do
that's me is a dog right that's me dogee did you pick the
dog no i did i maybe i did honestly that's i no that's not
me i think that's pippa i think i'm player two okay okay
okay i mean i just accidentally picked a dog good sure does
that mean we're done but how come there's no color next to
player four why are they gray double do double die because
like it's just how colors work okay okay are we all good now
you might need you might need to turn up the volume you
might need to turn up the volume blast it i can't i can't
adjust it without exiting the menu again we got it just tab
out basic necessity you can't you can't tab out looming
totally shit tabbing out if i tab out it'll break the game
for you guys wait there's only three players fuck what
happened to our fourth player it's because it was gray now i
can have a color sign to it i redo i redo enter it's okay
it's okay why don't we just do online because online's gonna
crash i swear to god it was i swear to god I swear to God it
wasn't gonna be that bad.
I swear to God it wasn't gonna be that bad.
I blamed her.
Local creator.
Oh my god.
It's just an easier name than I think how it is.
You can play cards against humanity.
No.
We're playing Monopoly.
Can I not throw this game away?
Like it just has to be this game forever?
Okay how about like Pippa teams up with somebody?
i can do it he's created new game no not the living board
monopoly rabbits rabbits rabbits we're not even rabbits the
rabbits okay those things are f tier those are like
oopalupas but stupid oh there you rapid rabbit and then
pippa an affiliate can beat wait why is an ai again yeah i'm
just gonna make pipp affiliate in the this thing i think
that's okay okay yeah make me Yeah, I'm gonna push that at
you.
Okay.
I'm ready.
All right.
We start start the game We did it.
We fucking did it clap it up chat Oh my god.
It only took like 80 years.
Okay.
We need No, there's no player five.
All we need is looming to raise the volume of the game and
then we should be set I don't know how to oh, me please
kitchen tap out and raise the volume of the video game At
three because it's fucking loud on my end.
How about 15?
Yeah, but you can turn it down on you fine fine you're
sweating where's my sound mixer sound mixer oh my god okay i
don't know how to get it hearts in chat for us okay okay
it's coming okay okay i got it it says the game oh we
already know the smell of the game is this loud enough here
why is loomy so quiet now What about S of it?
What the fuck?
Why is Lumi quiet?
Why are you so quiet?
Why?
Did you turn yourself down, Lumi?
What is this human doing?
Lumi, you accidentally turned yourself down instead of the
rest of the game.
Lumi, you sound like I said.
This is Sparta, and then I kicked you down an effing hole.
You already did that in whatever shit.
Sorry, I don't take notes from like midgets, okay?
Like, actually speak up, Pipsqueak.
How tall are you, Bits?
How tall are you right now?
You sound like Archer, do you want a good day?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, at least I have a brain unlike you.
You know what's funny is that I can barely hear Loomy's
insults back.
So I know.
Me too.
I thought I might listen to alien signals from Mars.
Like, it's like hearing somebody fight back like 200 miles
away.
I know.
I'm playing Ender's game and she's the aliens.
Like, she's like on the moon just shouting back at you.
All right, Lance Armstrong, chill out, bro.
We know you faked it.
Can we just, is it good?
Can we just do this?
Bro, you know, you're so quiet.
Your volume is still low, nerd?
What the fuck?
You're like 50% of what your original volume was.
This isn't my fault, Chad.
No, Phelan, this is 100% your fault.
Can we be, is this good?
Can we just go with this?
Hey, guys, maybe we should test this out before we stream.
Can we just go like this?
Is it good?
Is it better now?
Nobody believed me.
I did what I did.
No, you're still like 50% quieter.
I don't know what you did but you just turn it on discord
now We'll just have to fix it.
I literally turn it up to where it was Good her volume's
good or go.
I literally turned it up to where I was.
This is bullshit Okay, we're good.
We're good.
Fuck it.
Fuck this.
All right.
We're good.
Let's go.
Let's go Let's go roll the dice roll the dice.
Roll the dice.
Yeah
All right, am I the dog?
I think so?
Am I the dog?
No, I am not.
It's somebody else.
I can do whatever you want to be.
You whatever you want to be because this is remote play and
everyone's playing on one computer.
Okay, never mind.
Yeah, okay, yeah, yeah.
You're the dog dog.
You're the dog.
All right, that's me.
You're the king.
I got five.
My controller buzzes every time.
Okay, there's the rabbit.
I'm the bear.
No, Pippa's the rabbit.
Pippa's.
I'm the bear.
Wait, Pippa's the rabbit.
Pippa, be the rabbit.
I'm the pookie bear.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
I'm, I'm like ending my stream because my like connection is
dying.
Oh, oh shit.
Did you roll the die for yourself or did somebody else saw
it?
I didn't roll it.
It wasn't me.
It wasn't touching.
Okay.
Now it's my turn.
You rolled a nine.
I'm going to bomb you.
Why are you getting so defensive?
Shut the fuck up.
It's not my problem.
I didn't do anything wrong.
Don't crush your donkey.
What?
Why me?
Six!
Number one, the beast!
I'm last!
We're going!
We fucking doing it!
Hey, hey, hey!
First is the worst, second is second best, and third is the
golden bird.
What am I?
I'm five.
Oh, you're in the clock chair.
Oh.
Joy, we made it really comfy for you.
All right, here we go.
Roll the dice!
Who's here?
It's Pippa!
Pippa roll the dice!
Now I'm laughing bad.
Wait, what happened to Pippa?
Are we rolling forward?
Wait.
All right.
Ripped Pippa, dude.
I'm playing the fucking game!
All right.
Say, okay, wait, who's...
Who's playing this right now?
Is Pippa playing?
That's Pippa.
Touch your buttons.
Okay, we're gonna auction.
What?
Ah!
Ladies, ladies, ladies.
Ladies, ladies.
Pippa!
Pippa, why didn't you...
Why didn't you...
Why didn't you click auction, Pippa?
I ain't you!
Why didn't you click auction?
Guys, we're just starting to watch this.
Hello, ladies and gentlemen.
Today we're going to figure out how difficult it is Monopoly
really and we're in a future Donkey Bird.
What do you think about Monopoly so far?
I think it's pretty fun so far.
I'm enjoying it.
Especially on remote play.
It seems pretty fun.
She longs as idly as she breathes.
Alright, Luffy, how are you feeling?
This is shit.
This is fucking terrible.
You're all controlling my mouth.
Just hit the fucking button.
Just hit me.
You clicked auction.
Just hit it.
Hit okay.
I didn't touch it.
Hit okay, Pippa.
My hands are under the dead.
My game crashed.
Oh, she hit it.
There we go.
We got it.
Yeah.
Game crash?
Okay, wait.
Can I buy the auction or what?
Yeah, we can auction this.
I want a bid.
A bid.
No, it's purple's turn.
Yeah, purple is your turn.
Oh, you want to withdraw?
My game crashed!
Piffa, get it together.
Get it together!
Okay, I'm gonna all chat!
I'm gonna bid 100 bucks!
I'm gonna have a giga chat and nobody can stop me.
Oh my god!
I haven't walked you, Nurtia.
What could you bid?
I bid 100!
I'll bid 100 too.
Whoa!
Whoa, that's fucking where I bid 100 as well.
That's a railway.
You know you're bidding on top of our bids, right?
Lumi, you're blue.
You're blue.
No, no, no, no, oh, I'm blue.
Fuck, Pippa's dead.
You just went wrong?
No, Pippa can join back.
It's remote played.
That's the thing.
She can join back when.
You have to tap out every time it's a sacrifice we're
willing to make she can literally join back anytime because
it's literally Okay, here's what we do.
Here's what we do.
Thank you.
Jokey cares.
I'm like loomy You just like blondes.
This is this is blondism.
You're blonde If everybody distracted I can do this.
Oh shit What?
Shut up!
This is not fair!
Look at him!
I was gonna walk you!
Oh my god, Doki with the steel!
Oh, with the steel!
Okay, okay, my turn, my turn.
Roll dice, roll dice!
Motherfucker!
Oh my god, fuck you, Doki.
Fuck your taxes.
I am not a fan of the government.
Fuck!
Yay!
I knew where this was the right idea.
This is bullshit Okay, Toki if I roll another number to end
up on your railroad I'm gonna come over to your house and
effing put a track on your face
Okay, it's did we did we get Pippa back in?
We're gonna run Yeah, I'm buying I'm buying don't clear my
don't clear my nerd don't clear my nerds Fine yonkers.
I'm having a rantle and I'm on an avenue all right here we
go yeah it's my turn i already got a property before i went
is that crazy guys so you're gonna be broke fuck up
where are you going yeah i'm going a seven i got a car no
sound effect if that's the nearest railroad if unknown you
may buy from the bank if owned pay owner twice the rent to
which they otherwise entitled what oh i can do buy it too oh
my god everything is going for just fucking bullshit
brilliant this is your fault it's not my fault it's it's
probably my fault but but to be fair again it's all my fault
that's not you can't just blame it for i'm not obama oh
don't blame it on me Back I don't want to trade with
anybody.
Okay, do I just end my turn?
Trade me trade me the spirit of teamwork.
I have to believe in communism.
Do we okay?
Do we do we invite it back?
Yo, yo, yo team up check your PayPal.
No, no, no, what the fuck?
No Loomy silence the women are speaking.
Dokey Please team up with me What do I get out of it?
I get out of it, though.
You get, whoa, roads to rail.
Okay, but like how many roads though?
Now get ready for a boulevardian.
What?
What the fuck is this Pippa lock?
Did Pippa, did Pippa even like, okay, is that Pippa playing?
Actually, yeah.
Oh, you got your sound effects dog?
Holy frick.
What the hell?
How do we build the houses again?
You have to own all the colors.
You just have to land on it again and then you can build a
house you have to land on it again okay give me the fucking
property so wait yes buy no option no i want to get the blue
one i love the blue property don't get i didn't click
anything what do you mean i only did it once i have a
history oh because i did it once i have a history yeah
that's what it means that's what it means There he is.
You didn't.
That's all.
Oh my god.
You guys have to buy the entire planet, dude.
You got that more expensive places.
My stonks are going up.
Okay, it's my turn.
Please give me a double.
Land on my property, coward.
You won't.
Shut up.
I would rather go to jail.
I like trains.
I'm going to jail.
No!
You haven't done the crime yet, or you haven't got caught.
Oh my god.
Tax evasion does fail.
You haven't got caught yet.
You're so lucky.
Is that the end of my turn?
Yeah, that is.
Just go end turn.
I think so.
Just press enter for me.
Fine.
Okay, I'll press end for you.
It's your turn.
Dude, I have nothing.
Oh, don't you think you can control other people's boards
again.
I have nothing going for me.
Oh, I've got the pass.
Free parking.
You just won $5.
Dude, that's $20 in some places.
Parking is expensive.
Yeah.
You guys want to eat anything, by the way?
Ooh.
Who's that?
Well, you guys are all landing on properties.
That's unfair.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tell me about it.
I own a singular blue property.
That's called karma.
We don't control other people's boards.
Does anyone want to, like, auction their property off?
No, no, no.
Yes, yes, yes.
I would like to auction their property off.
I would like to auction jail.
It's a government property.
I'll steal it.
You want to auction it off?
Let me...
No, no, no, no.
I'm good.
Why?
It's good.
I'm literally behind you guys, and I get to auction
literally nothing.
Buy nothing.
I'm going to land on someone's property.
I'm going to roll my head in.
You're going to commit a tax fraud.
I didn't commit tax fraud.
I just really have one property.
No, I visited EVP.
He said it was a really good cupcake.
I don't know what you want from me.
Here.
Let me roll.
I just killed myself.
I got a double.
Okay, we're still back.
All right.
Nice.
Wait, is this really good?
Yeah, yeah, this is electric company.
You own electricity.
Oh.
Chat.
I'm now on a watcher type Pokemon.
Thumbnail!
Oh, no.
Now we have to pay Thalian for...
Lumi, turn up your SFX.
Yeah, pay me every time Pippa's internet crashes.
Frank, pull me Comcast.
I fucking hate Comcast.
I'm going to Fiber.
I'm moving and I'm getting Fiber.
Yeah, Fiber is pretty fucking nice.
Lumi, Lumi, look at my eyes.
Turn up the SFX volume in chat, please.
Ouch.
He wants to hear the- Why is only five, dude?
Because it's fucking loud!
It's not music.
It's not loud at all!
I don't understand!
Like, I think- It's so loud!
You don't need these sounds!
Okay, we don't need 25.
I don't- Why is the system louder than- Do you like trains,
yes or no?
Like, just- Do you like trains, yes or no?
I think of your goddamn mind!
No, I was acoustic.
Okay, fine, I'll roll again.
Roll your dice.
You gotta sneak- Please, roll- roll- I'm dead again.
Oh, what the- Oh, you're the four?
Who the four?
Nice, nice, nice.
Wait, does anyone own this?
I don't think so.
We are so Barak.
We are so Barak, boys!
St. James Place!
I'm gonna touch it and purchase it.
There it is.
What?
Why did you wear it like that?
Call yourself, Philean, Rockefeller.
Yeah, my turn!
Yeah!
Yup, yup.
Chat, I'm about to run an effing Monopoly on these effing
nerds.
Wait, that's the game.
Okay, that was not funny.
What?
What are you doing?
You're doing so good, Philean.
My water works too.
for does anyone own nobody owns the properties yeah so close
nice now you can't have the red hello it's mine now man
that's right i mean i'll sell it to you i'll sell it to you
okay yeah how about the games 800 i'm gonna tell about the
games look real estate is like really it's a difficult
market right now pay school fees you're going back Oh,
you're going broke.
You're going broke, nerd.
Going back to school.
Congratulations on graduating.
I mean, $50 for student debt, that's a good bargain.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
How many properties do I own?
I own three.
I have three.
I can't hear this effects at all, me either.
Okay.
I hear it.
It's like, it says there's not a lot of sound effects.
It's just go.
Yeah, I know, but they're still laughing low.
Like, what?
you want them to be it's just gonna be like a ding sound or
whatever i know i know i want to hear my dings she wants to
hear our dings guys people will literally grind for 30 hours
on ruinscape to hear a singular ding her attention span is
so low that she needs to hear her dings
oh wow a hundred guzzies guzzie overdrive enabled
Did you crash us?
No.
No, she's trying to lower her volumes and stuff.
I'm trying to lower the volume on my side.
It's literally just a ding sound effect.
This has been like, I swear, this collab has been the
hardest to sound balance in my life.
In between everyone yelling?
This has been the, my sound guy literally like gave up.
Yeah, it's been a little.
Double!
Double?
Do that, but...
Oh, yeah, she's getting the expensive properties now.
Oh, yeah.
She might get boardwalk.
No, I didn't.
No, she's gonna be too broke to buy boardwalk.
No, she can afford it.
No, she having skipped it.
Oh, I bought it.
Yeah, you skipped it.
You skipped it.
Well, I passed goals and pumpkins.
Was that my will?
No, it's just a community chest.
What is a community chest?
Oh, life is just a community chest.
Somebody died.
Oh no, she killed my dad.
My dog died
That's fucked up my dog died that's fucked up because life
insurance doesn't mean old age.
What did you do to your dog
Don't worry about it don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it.
Your dog is fucked up Please please please you can't grab
life insurance if it's old age You can invite me again.
No you can't yeah Because they would never give you life
insurance if it's like if you're too old
Okay, thank you.
Oh, wait, who am I trade with we want to trade with why are
you trading?
Oh, somebody somebody click trade back in here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah Okay, all right.
Oh my god if somebody press and she's she's out No, stop
There's a bank club button It would be a shame if somebody
just pressed on What the fuck?
Oh, she's going to jail.
Listen.
You might as well be bankrupt.
God dang it, dude.
Get fun, Billy.
Why am I on the gulag?
I literally rolled a double.
It doesn't make me invincible.
No.
Why?
It's because you rolled a double.
That means that, yeah, that was illegal.
You just did an illegal thing.
Why the end of every game like that?
You're just mad because I'm putting a boss in it down and
I'm about to buy boardwalk when I grow up.
And you guys, everyone on board.
Hey, my turn.
Let's see.
Boy, does anyone own that?
Nope.
What is that?
Is that another utility?
Oh, you can't have a monopoly on the utility now.
I own the water.
Okay, well, if you own the water and I only have
electricity, we can put them together and create toasters
and bathtubs.
We can sell them as a product for Darwinism.
what do you think what the this is exactly why she's in jail
this is why we've like kept her in jail i'm not in jail i'm
visiting i'm definitely in jail right now i'm just i'm i'm
doing nothing play for work thank you pipa okay
yeah i knew how i knew how owning that railway that pipa
auctioned off was a good idea I don't- Who's close to me?
You can't roll again?
You got snake ass.
You got double.
You gotta roll again.
Pippa bail me out of jail.
No!
Don't bail me out.
Please say hi to Philly and in jail.
Yeah, go say hi to me.
She needs some company.
Don't leave it.
She's gonna influence you.
Bye.
Pippa!
Get hacked, idiot.
Hello.
Oh, no, she- It's my land.
Okay, here.
Oh, you actually pressed train.
What you actually press trade
Are you are you a bear?
Yeah, I'm the bear.
What do you want to trade?
Okay, here I'll give you Give you Enough you get out of
jail.
Wait, what?
You know the bell her out?
You gonna post your bell?
Why are you bailing your out wait silent silent?
She speaks what is it pippa You got you gotta give me
someone What do you want?
What do you want?
She wants to electricity.
Oh!
You would do that to me?
I would.
You think I'm gonna give up my early investments just
because you're gonna give me an effing...
You're trying to dogecoin me.
You're trying to pump and dump me.
No, you should take it.
It's a very good deal.
You are a one and a half.
You're a very good deal.
You're not a much good deal.
Like honestly, I feel like you're in jail right now,
Villian.
You should not be negotiating You know what?
Villian sit on the ground I'm not even blink twice.
Are you just gonna quit the game?
The first rage quitter right here Here's my counter offer.
Here's my counter offer.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
I'm gonna remove how do I play?
You have to remove it on your own on your own screen.
What?
Oh on your side you see your the side with all the cards,
you gotta click it on yourself.
Oh.
What?
Underneath your money.
You see all those cards on the right side?
Yeah.
Just click.
Obviously, no, because your cursor's not on it.
Obviously, I know you don't understand.
Yes.
Okay.
There you go.
No, you don't want no frick this.
Just double click it.
Yeah, if you don't want it, just click it again.
Press.
Okay, click it on it.
Click it and then press enter because it removes the card.
I'm not interested.
Okay, fine.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
I'm almost there.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Honestly, like, I'm impressed that Philly is making these
demands when she's in fucking jail.
Like, yeah.
All right, you had that thing?
Right, now, how do I...
Pippa's literally visiting you in jail, like the only person
that's willing to visit you.
She brought you your favorite brownies and shit?
The rest of us just pretend you don't exist right now.
Can you stop?
I hate you.
You know what?
Gratio.
When I get out of jail, I'm going to become the next Warren
Buffett, and you're going to be the buffet.
You understand me?
I don't think...
able to because you're literally you're in literally you
literally have a police record no one's gonna hire you now
and when you walk into the store like Gustavo afraid to
check on your lawyers I'm gonna stab you in the neck with a
shank oh I just won't go there okay I lied I'll actually be
like what do you want you'd be like a number seven I'd be
like sorry the ice cream machine broke okay how do I how do
I say I'm not interested like what is this that's bad
backspace backspace at the bottom of this exchange philian
i'd order burgers from you okay see you have a customer okay
i'm just uh i'm i'm just happy i'm happy i'm doing my own
thing and i'm not going to oh philian you're gonna visit oh
my god you're gonna visit philian oh he's just visiting so
she feels more superior than you feel so bad everyone give
me a small loan of a million yeah bye okay see you later oh
i'm good pass i'm good all my friends are dead yo push me to
the edge all my friends are dead yeah push me ah sucks sucks
to suck philian fuck hey how about you pay me 14 dollars by
the way i brought you pizza to the jail oh yeah you tried to
run away from me and i haven't caught you you like you tried
one I quick scoped on the way out.
Okay, wait, I can roll dice three times or I can pay 50
bucks.
You have to roll a double if you just pay $50.
It's literally $50.
Shut up, woman.
It's literally 50.
Keep her in jail, doggie.
Keep her.
Yeah, but what if you don't get?
If you don't get that number, then you'll never get out.
I should have paid the 50.
I told you, you should have paid a 50.
Nobody listens to me.
Like how nobody listens to me about Monopoly.
We can't have any fun doing this stream.
Come on.
Okay.
We're not even going to go.
Shut up.
Look at this trending on Twitter.
Hashtag free my boy Phelan.
Let's not.
That would be like the fastest way it dies.
Look, I got your double.
Oh.
Oh, there she goes.
There I go.
Is that a chance card?
Whoa.
I'm pretty sure I'm going to pay.
If that's the nearest railroad.
Oh, another railroad.
Do I own this?
Oh, man.
my god oh i own this this is insane luck okay but i don't
own i already owned this so i don't get to buy it you know
fill in another problem let's go this is this is fucked up
the system is broken it's all rigged i hate capitalism no
it's another community chest let's go it's my birthday happy
birthday
Thank you guys.
It's my birthday.
Happy 50th.
Hope you get out of my third row.
Dude, I'm even in jail and I bought your birthday gift.
Okay, nice.
Alright, thank god.
Alright, that's good.
I...
Yeah!
Oh, fire!
I got birthday money!
Let's go!
I just got birthday money too.
Dude, this is so stupid, man.
Hey, I've got two of your doubles, Villion.
Maybe you should have paid 50 fucking dollars.
Why did I get skipped, though?
Why did I get skipped?
This is madness.
This is gonna be new if you paid your fucking money.
Wait, but I didn't, like, why did I get to roll again?
No, you didn't.
You only got to roll one.
Oh, you owed money.
You're so good to the homeless people.
Cat girl losing to a little tomato.
Look, she's giving you another bail option.
Who is doing this now?
I'm not giving you my profit.
Okay, come on Phyllian.
Sorry.
I love my women too much.
Calm down.
What?
Take it back.
Dude, I'm not gonna give you my money or my property.
I need that.
I'm not asking for your money.
You're never gonna play Phyllian if you do.
I know that property is worth that much.
That's a good deal Phyllian.
No, I know it's worth that much.
I don't want this.
I'm not interested.
That's a good deal.
I know what I'm scared.
I know what I'm worth.
Yeah, I'm not what I'm worth.
Out of commitment?
I'm not sure.
She's literally in jail.
She's scared of everything right now.
Like, I don't know what's going on in jail, but I'm pretty
sure.
Changes the person.
She just needs more time in jail to finally get desperate.
Look, everybody's getting doubles except for you, Phyllian.
You're super sizing your menu?
Oh, nice.
Oh, shit.
I'm going to jail a little double and get bored.
No more men.
Oh, there's still the green the greens are all right.
Here's another chance or you could pay $50 Shut up.
Okay, fine.
Welcome back.
How's it?
You're a millionaire committing a crime.
All right.
Did you enjoy the spam?
Yeah.
Oh, my blood hurts.
See you weren't gonna get double anyway
It would be funny if she goes to the jail again.
You tell me, you tell me.
If she goes to jail, I'm gonna uninstall.
Hey, you got $25.
Consultancy fee.
Yeah, you got it.
They catered me for advice.
Who?
Who's they?
Because they're not taking money from us.
My viewers donated five subs.
What?
Who is this?
25 subs to get Philly and out of jail.
Does no one own this?
No, I got more trains!
I've got another railroad!
I'm gonna kill, I'm gonna kill this bitch.
Guys, I'm owning the transportation!
Hello, fellow unlucky people of the Monopoly board.
I would like to propose an alliance.
Wait, who are you proposing to?
I'm proposing an alliance against Doggy Bird!
Me?
What did I do?
She's got too much generational wealth.
like it i just i literally just bought the railroad i what
do you mean i made my money you're paying doggy right now
it's okay it's okay it's okay i'm gonna buy boardwalk right
now yeah okay yeah sure and like two turns one is my turn
but you know yeah okay two turns he's gonna get boardwalk we
believe in you just effing let me cook shit oh you get the
green that's not that's not what we by anybody.
Okay, I take it.
Wait, you're going to own that monopoly.
That's so expensive.
Oh!
Wait, I can have a monopoly.
See, I'm just gonna get a good one.
I have a mon- I can get a monopoly!
Dude, let me own a property!
Please, please, please, please, please, please, I'm gonna
scream.
Hey, does that good or bad?
Well, we'll see.
Please, you guys don't ever know what else I'm impore.
I really blocked the monopoly.
Wait, no, she just bought that, didn't she?
Yeah.
I just bought that.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I'm with a dokey bird girl.
That's just, I can't look down the red line.
That's she.
Just bought the old railroad.
She is me.
Wait, you have three railroad stations?
Yeah, I do.
Motherfucker.
That is so annoying.
Okay, Lumi, you want to do an alliance?
I can own the railroad and you can own the property.
I mean, you should have an alliance because I literally own
the one monopoly you want Chad, is this real I offer you I
offer you one red space for your green space All right, you
know what?
Yeah, I'll take that deal.
I'll take it.
Yeah, good deal.
Good deal Does anyone want to give me one of the best trade
deals in American?
I'm gonna jump
Wow, this is crazy This is crazy That's insane Oh, okay
Yeah, hi Pippa Wait, what are you giving here?
What do you want from here?
I'm breaking this alliance before it starts You need more to
treat me Your power I think you're attracted to power
actually Don't you like that?
Pippa, do you want to be part of this alliance?
We can do it no, no, we can win Wait, what about this?
Don't pick me!
She's disestablishmentarian.
I believe in the government, or I don't, depending on what
you like.
I need my green monopoly, Pippa!
Yeah, she can have her green monopoly.
I can have my red monopoly.
Everybody is happy.
Everybody's happy.
If you trade away your red, she'll never get the green
monopoly, and don't you want her to be happy?
If you give me a yellow.
Why am I on this business meeting, dude?
I'll give you an orange if you give me a yellow.
You went to jail.
You can't be in this business meeting.
You have a record.
You can't let you in right now.
Someone offer me something?
If you want, you can either have an orange or a yellow.
I'll show you.
You literally have two properties.
What are you gonna offer us?
I can offer you my love.
You have two properties.
This is the problem with America.
up okay yeah just do this deal yeah deal sure throw in 50
bucks do it i'll take it just do counter offer and then you
can make her throw in i'll take it no this one's for pipa
thank you yeah she needs it right now oh she was like oh she
was so close to boardwalk she was almost there i'm gonna get
boardwalk someone's got to get that oh oh wait you don't own
any you don't own houses or hotel anything yeah yeah yeah
you're fine all right we can trade if you want yeah let's
trade trade me trade me trade me trade me if you're not part
of this conversation sorry who are you you want you want the
green yeah and then i'll give you the Green.
Okay, this is a good how do I do it?
You press it and then enter.
Add nice.
Yeah, and then trade you.
And then...
You know what?
Because I feel especially generous right now, I'll give you
that deal.
Thank you.
I'll give you that deal.
Wow, thank you.
Oh, sorry, deal, yes.
Wow, and then accept.
Yep.
I'm happy with this monopoly I'm happy with this monopoly as
well.
There's Monopoly, guys!
Philean, what is wrong?
Consume the rich.
Oh, I can build houses.
Woo!
All right.
Give it a turn.
Yeah.
Yeah, I can't build anything, so...
It's my turn.
It's your turn, Philean.
Guys, hurry up.
Get on the property.
I'm not about to spend the next two hours screaming over
being broke.
Oh, hey, thank you again for the water.
I mean, people need a shower, so it's understandable,
Philean, me the shower.
Yogi, I don't know where you live, but I have a very special
set of skills.
It's very, very nice of you.
I will client you and I will give you a hug in real life.
Oh, nice.
You're welcome.
Put the shotgun.
In the shower.
There's your water bills, bitch.
I'll take the water that I paid 15 bucks for and give it
back to you.
And then I'll ask for a refund.
Now I can see why Phelion went to jail, guys.
Why?
She's a dangerous axe murderer.
I went to jail because I paid back my crime.
She's a danger to society.
I'm not.
It deserves to be locked up, man.
I need to wear shoes, man.
Ooh, doubles.
Oh, my God.
I got a double?
Whoa.
Does anyone own that?
Just so you guys know, I have more money than all of you.
Yeah, because you never bought anything.
Yeah.
So?
You owe...
No, I have to pay 200.
drink i have to pay taxes oh wow that's crazy that's crazy
i'm too rich now i got to the next tax bracket that's all
i'm gonna be visiting i'm gonna visit jail yo tell me to be
high all right i can't believe it okay i fucking i went to
the next tax bracket she's looking at the less fortunate
people to remind of how she came up to be like, I'll never
be like million.
Okay.
I'm a robot.
Hey, nice people.
Hey.
Nice people.
Oh, you got Monopoly too.
See, we all got Monopolys.
Yeah.
We all got Monopolys now.
All three of us.
Yeah.
Wait, do you want to trade me water?
At least give me a chance.
I know you have nothing I want.
I got a limit here by M-Stream, and I don't want to hit
here.
You literally have nothing I want.
I have a railroad.
Oh, you need to go back and go again.
You reset itself.
You got $400.
Look at how nobody has landed on.
boardwalk yet no this might be Philly's chance this could be
Philly's chance yeah I believe in you Philly you know there
have to be poor people being minused about the point I know
you're right Philly is like the one who reminds us like
where we started oh yeah you got community chairs oh you
don't have to pay you don't have you don't own anything so
you don't have to pay She's too poor.
She doesn't even have taxes to pay.
Yeah.
I mean, it's nice that she finds pleasure in the little
things, you know.
Yeah.
She's here to remind us about that.
Chad, you do have a chance.
What's this?
Oh, is this an art community chest?
Oh, my God.
Nobody's getting these last two.
Nobody.
Oh, I got a jail free card.
I feel like you want to trade.
This is truly a privilege of being.
Such a rich privilege, mind you.
I'll give you 50 bucks.
No, that's not worth 50 dollars.
I'll give you 60 bucks.
I'll give you 69 dollars.
Keep going up.
All you have is money.
Give me two of your prop.
Yeah, all you do, all you have is money.
Wait, she's ready.
Oh, thank God.
I still have a chance.
Oh, shit.
Oh, you luxury tax.
Oh, no, you were- Pippa bought so many nice things.
Wait, you're about to go broke, nerd.
until you land on my square how does it feel you're gonna
land on my houses and you're gonna be like oh i'm so sorry
pippa sorry sorry let's go buy buy that shit hell yeah mods
mods your mods can't help you now philian okay okay i think
your mods would support us more than you one two three i
need a four or a six if i got a four or six i am more barack
than obrama all right check what literally she's gonna be
back oh you get it wow I'm getting
she's not back she's not back at all hey Philly you don't
need her to buy the land right yeah wait how much property
does she have Indians have rights she has three wait three
yeah wait she's preventing you from getting a monopoly Lumi
you should trade over her oh Hey, Philean.
What up?
Maybe what you offer and sister.
I'll give you.
I'll give you the blue spot.
I'll give you that little light blue one.
Okay.
Wait, make a deal.
Give me a deal, dog.
Which one are you?
Are you the dog or the hat?
You're the hat.
I'm the hat.
All right, hat.
I think make an offer.
Yeah, all right.
Here's my offer.
All right.
Don't forget.
I'm on the left.
You give me this orange thing.
Okay.
You want my orange thing.
Four.
And then I give you.
How do I fucking do it?
and then you go to and then what how'd I do it oh yeah oh
not so easy now is it my sound doesn't you hover over to
yourself that's how you do it I'll give you this blue thing
there you go you are such a nerd I'll go in a hundred
dollars so you can get out of jail twice no no I should take
that money you you should take the money i want 200 i'm
giving you two monopolies no i said 200 i said i don't way
too much money i'm not going bankrupt but you're never in
your property unless you give me an actual offer i'm giving
you a property i don't yeah i know and you're gonna get sick
here's a plan we wait until philian gets bankrupt and then
you can take the property for free philian look i know
you're not good at investing but i promise if i give you
this property you'll have a chance to survive shut up dog
don't try to help she doesn't want i said loomie she doesn't
want to have any money i know you didn't go to school this
is hard to drive you owe me money you owe me money
investments deal shut up i said give me 200.
i said 200 she's a lost cause don't help her i said 200
she's gonna drag you down loomie she's gonna make you
You're getting that?
No, Toby.
Don't listen to her.
I'll give her 200.
It's fine.
What's she going to do with it besides pay her monopolies?
You're getting scammed.
You get it.
No, this will pay off in the long run.
I have faith.
I'll give you 201 dollars.
When she goes on an egomaniacal rampage because she has the
monopoly, she'll probably just trip on her treadmill again
and fall.
There's three blue squares.
I'm only going to own two.
Are you guys done?
On her fucking treadmill again.
Okay.
I want 250.
for that joke.
No, motherfuckers!
See, I told you!
I told you, Lumi!
She's just getting five more!
And then asking and asking and asking and asking and asking!
No!
Not interested!
No, fuck you!
She needs to be put in her place!
That's fine.
No, that's cool.
That's cool.
Half of a hot dog?
She's a lost cause!
You can't keep stupid!
I'm gonna roll one right now.
Check this out.
Alright, do it.
Oh wait, I'll roll one like.
Nice roll.
All right, my turn.
I'm so fucking scared every time Doki rolls the dice.
Why are you guys scared?
She's got everything.
Oh, no.
Who's this?
It's Pippa.
Holy shit.
Now I'm scared.
Fuck.
I don't like this Pippa Monopoly.
Pippa has a monopoly now.
She's getting rich.
She was the secret.
You could have prevented this.
This is all your fault, Phyllian.
She was the secret business mom, girl.
It's all your fault.
This was Phyllian's fault, yeah.
Why am I an epic McDonald's employee, dude?
What are these rules, dude?
What?
And she gets 150?
She was the hidden.
The capillism is so fucking strong today.
Don't like this.
Wait, can I manage my properties?
I manage my properties.
I should have managed my properties too.
Oh my god, it's so much money.
Sure.
Wait, how do I do it?
It's shift?
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's so fucking expensive!
It is.
Jesus.
Okay, I'm just gonna play.
Because I still got properties to buy.
Right?
Fuck.
Seven.
Where's seven?
Oh, yeah, it was a dragon.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
Someone should hurry and own the Humble, you know, keep me
humble.
That's all.
That's all Keep me humble.
Keep you humble.
You can sit higher and lower those in there with me.
Yeah, we'll buy another property.
You're gonna be broke.
You're gonna be broke soon, Lumi.
That should be fine.
It should be fine.
Oh my god, how do I do this?
What are you doing?
You go back, back.
Yeah.
Hit bait for quantum reasons.
Enter, enter.
Okay, we're good.
My turn, my turn.
I'm gonna roll one.
You can't, you literally can't.
He can't even roll a one.
You got doubles though?
I'm all my way!
To tomato town.
What is this?
Yeah!
You owe 200 dollars.
Wow, what a turn, Billy?
Stop, what a turn.
Please, please, please, give me please.
Great turn.
Just please, please.
When was the last time?
Million bought property, by the way.
I'm sorry.
Like, her second turn is a game.
Oh, I can roll again.
Great.
Wow, I sure can't wait to land on a railroad.
Hey, look.
You can't land on a railroad.
You can't get one.
You get to visit jail as well.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Hey, this is a video game.
I'm going to shake you in a jail cell and I'm never going to
find you.
You're just visiting.
There are guards around you.
There's guards.
I'm a level 7 rogue and I took something.
refuted my feet i feel unsafe i feel like i'm gonna die yeah
i feel unsafe who owns this nobody oh my god it's the one
house i didn't know oh no you own it oh i gave you that
remember i gave you this yeah you did so wait what i did i
promise if i'm gonna jump over what i did for you bail me
out i wonder like where's mine oh i would bail doki out yeah
i'd bail it out What else is a thief's thing, you know?
I'll put...
What about like a phillian thing?
Yeah, you're not included.
You're not included.
You were in jail.
I'm about to go to the basket.
Guys, there's a potential where I might go bankrupt.
You can tell me this game is based on skill.
It's on skill.
It's all skill.
It's all about investing.
It's not.
You would understand if you went to school.
Okay, Lumi.
Lumi.
You wanted to trade or not.
Yeah, yeah, let's do the trade.
Okay, we'll do the trade on the next turn.
You give me the orange, I give you the blue.
Okay.
We'll do it, we'll do it.
We'll do it.
All right.
Oh my god, Pippa's all in on her monopoly.
That's fucking scary.
I don't like that.
Yeah, she has a, she has a scary monopoly right now.
Woo!
Good job.
Where is she going?
Oh!
God damn it.
What comes around, goes around.
Shit!
Oh wow!
Oh!
You get it!
What is happening?
You can't enjoy it, bro!
Too much!
That's what you get.
What do you want?
Pellian, I'll come and make a deal.
Okay, what's the deal?
Let me know.
You know, look, and this is how it goes.
And this is how it goes.
Oh, he has to come to office.
You offered me a property and you want...
He's a fucking loathe shark.
What do you want?
What do you want from me?
Okay, you can stop.
I stopped.
Oh, oh.
A little more, Fabi.
A little more.
I'll give you a zill.
She's desperate.
No, she's so desperate.
It's $9.
She is so desperate for property.
You can literally ask for more money.
She's so desperate for her.
You know she wants a property.
She's so fucking desperate.
You have to ask for more.
I know everything we go to the business and I can make sure
you're a millionaire.
You know she'll say yes if you ask for more money.
You don't want to pay it.
Oh We got property boys Yeah, get a hundred though Hell yeah
I overpay much a lot But it's fine Just let me not touch
Pippa's land Freaks me out She's gonna shoot me with a
shotgun I will Loomy, loomy, loomy Loomy, loomy It's not
property Oh my god I thought I was Honestly, I was going to
be I was really scared That I was going to go bankrupt But
like Everything seems to go well.
Okay, let's trade.
Let's trade, Lumi.
It all comes back to good old Philly.
It all comes back here.
I'll give you Connecticut Ave.
Just because of railroads?
Railroads aren't even a monopoly.
You can't monopolize railroads.
This country was built on railroads, Doki.
This country was built on the backbone of our whole society.
I'm Canadian.
Chat.
It's two hours, I threw that troll two hours.
Motherfuck.
A fucking leave.
Thank you, thank you.
If I get the last blue one, I promise I'll give it to you.
Shut up.
Wait, you never mind, never mind, I love you.
Look, she insulted you after you traded with me.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I didn't say shit, I didn't say shit.
No, I just spoke with my, my brain spoke before I did.
Sorry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was thinking with my dipstick.
I need that for Snickers.
Okay Wait, you- I don't think you should- I don't think you
should put more property.
You have like a hundred dollars.
The moment you land on another- Someone land on a space,
please.
Okay.
That's me!
It's your turn.
Chat, watch me roll boardwalk.
Yeah, I think you're way too far.
You're way too far from boardwalk.
What do you mean?
Welcome to Jackson, baby.
Look at everybody's using my railroad.
Donkey, donkey, donkey.
Oh, my God.
You know I'm rich, right?
I give it a hundred.
You trade me back.
I owe you one.
Yeah, but what are you going to trade for me?
I want a property.
I don't later eat.
Roof old.
Right?
I want a property, Phelian.
Okay, sorry.
I love my family and my wife, Can't afford to feed them
without them.
I can give it to you over time, but you're not the trust But
if you trade them away, you trade your family away.
You never have to feed them again.
Okay, but here's a thing Here's a thing.
I only love my mom and my bed.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
I will trade you back Eventually yeah, yeah, yeah.
Who crashed?
No, somebody crashed.
Oh wait, nobody crashed Oh, you tabbed out.
Okay.
Doki, you're gonna pay me back.
Doki, you're gonna pay me back You're gonna pay me back.
No deal.
We trade.
We trade for me.
I was so scared.
Okay.
She can't get the blues.
Don't wait.
We're all, we're still safe on boardwalk.
Yes.
Boardwalk is still safe.
We're still safe on boardwalk.
Oh, got it.
Is this up?
Is this the loomy?
Oh, it's the loomy territory.
Oh, it's $4.
Oh, thank God.
You know what?
You gave me a hundred, I'll give you four dollars.
Thanks, thank you, thanks, I appreciate it.
Hey, yeah, what's four dollars between friends?
Exactly, right?
Fippa, roll a four.
We just cost me nine.
Wait, I said three.
The owner's gotta stick together.
Wait, Chloe's getting more money, bro.
Wait, who the fuck is this?
Oh, that's me?
That's the one I put a house on!
All I'm saying, Kipa, is you allied with the wrong person.
Chad, are we cooked?
Shit, we're fucked in this game.
She's the only one with the house, too.
She's rich in the me and I own zero property.
Oh my god.
I fucking hate this shit.
I fucking hate these.
I'm actually gonna blow up this game.
I'm actually gonna blow up this fucking chain.
Oh my god, I was broke and now I'm rich.
I'm blowing up this.
train okay come on come on come on boardwalk boardwalk
boardwalk i'm charging my dice yaked up look all i'm saying
to me is that we gotta stick together we do i'll give you
whatever free can i land on green are you gonna land on
another railroad nice brilliant welcome welcome to the train
station welcome to my train station all right i thought
owning transportation was like the way to go who would have
thought wild ride.
Okay, bump and roll again.
Watch, boardwalk.
Oh, hey, snake eyes.
Double.
I'm done.
It's over.
Oh, my God.
Bipa, look, you got saved from bankruptcy.
He's good at all he's good.
Welcome back.
Thank you, Phelan.
Phelan, would you like to make a deal?
I don't think Philean is okay.
I think she's like...
I think she regrets suggesting Monopoly as her collab game.
You know, I think like...
Is that her neck breaking?
I think it's great that Philean is like our piggy bank.
You know?
Like...
Yeah!
She's like a lone shark, but without the muscle.
Yeah, yeah.
So, like, she's not a shark.
She's like a...
She's like a lone ant.
Three doubles, Phyllian?
No, she got...
She was lucky and got out of jail.
What's that over there?
What's over there?
No, she just missed it.
Oh, you know, if you hit that railroad, you could have cut
me from camping the last railroad.
Yeah.
You were the chosen one, Phyllian.
You could have stopped me from a monopoly on the trains.
Why'd you pass that up?
Someone present her.
Why can't you advance?
Oh, she got bored.
She can't afford boardwalk.
Because she's cheating on boardwalk.
With what money?
Money is for me.
This is crazy.
I spent my entire life shooting her boardwalk.
You can't even afford it.
Well, it's time for the auction.
Survival in the Pippa with the Pippa.
I'm gonna win this.
Wait, wait, okay, I'll bid, I'll bid, I'll bid.
You can only bid like...
You can't even afford it!
I think I'll...
You had no money!
Please, please, please, I'll do anything, please!
You don't have to play game right now!
Just withdraw!
You can't afford it!
Let me play, bro!
What is this?
That's good.
I did the million.
This is your fault.
Philly and thanks for giving me boardwalk.
I really appreciate it Philly.
I think I didn't discount.
This is absolutely your fault, Philly.
I told you guys to not ally with her.
I told you guys.
I'm like, DJ Kyle.
Nobody believed me.
I said like it's not.
We shouldn't.
We shouldn't alliance with her.
I'm gonna go to a store and I'm gonna have an epic netbook
and chill like I can't do this dude I can't do this we're
supposed to get more money in this game we're just gonna
bankrupt ourselves in the next three turns all right let's
see I want to put a house I'll put house in Indiana baby
land bridge passport where's my oh I got another die roll
let's go Yay!
You're just so bad.
This game has not even luck.
Who's this?
Oh, Philly, you can sell your property to Doki.
Yo, guys!
I'll buy that!
Oh, my fucking god.
Sell it to Doki for some money.
Yeah, Philly, you want to sell me this property, Philly?
Pull yourself up by your book.
Yeah, yeah.
You want to sell that property?
I'll buy that property.
No, I'm going to pass Gok like $200 and I'll build a kingdom
with it.
All right.
Sure.
I can start from nothing.
All I'm saying is Philean's been coping for a very long
time.
Okay, yeah, I like drugs.
What about it?
Good for your sanity.
You guys like vultures.
You're after you can prank on my grave or you're going to
steal whatever's left of me for as cheap as you can get it.
You guys are cursing!
Oh my god, we should not land more Pippa.
We should not land on any of Pippa's spot.
You're fucking dead if you do.
I'm saying, Philean, if you land on Pippa Square, I think
you actually have to declare bankruptcy.
Thank God.
Thank you, people.
Thank you.
Yay.
I can get out of jail now.
I know you're poor.
You needed it.
Yeah, yeah.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I've been on top times.
Double.
Is that my square?
Does that mean you land on Norwalk?
No.
Oh, you just missed it.
Oh, you're next to me.
Oh, shit.
You're brilliant.
I think you make a deal.
Pippa.
Stop.
negotiating with her i will give you a free pass give me
something okay i owe you my life yeah okay okay i'm gonna
save you and i owe you yeah okay yeah you can give that to
me give that to me purple give it to me purple you owe me
you owe me you owe me you owe me you owe me you owe me you
owe me you owe me you owe me you owe me you owe me you owe
me I don't even need you.
I don't even need you.
I'm way too happy.
And I kissed my girlfriend.
I found a new leader.
It's over.
You're gonna be okay.
Two or three.
Don't be upset.
You're done with you, Dylan.
You're done with...
You're dead on Twitch.
Don't call the titular.
Okay.
She's done with you.
I've canceled the YouTube rewards.
Sorry.
Freak this junk.
Holy shit.
Why are we all so fucking poor?
I'm going to put my headset Okay, I have to over a million
your allies are all gone Okay, what if I have a strategic
battle in the West?
Yeah, you've lost everybody You've lost everyone Oh, you got
the one billion spot, but you have enough money.
It's only six dollars Like it's six dollars
I hope you enjoy the six dollars.
Nice job, nice job.
Good money, Phyllian.
Good money.
Simple stalks.
What is that over there?
Is that the last railroad?
You got the last railroad!
Oh, fuck, you can't afford it!
Oh, shit!
If you give me a hundred dollars.
If you give me a hundred dollars, I'll buy it.
Wait, people can buy it, right?
Yeah, Pippa can buy it.
Yeah.
Just let Pippa buy it.
I don't even have options.
Yeah.
No, you auction it off.
You have to auction it off.
I have to auction it.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's no trade before have it.
I'm gonna withdraw it.
She has it on my magazine.
Don't worry.
I'm in this drawing.
I'm gonna win this.
Chad, watch this.
You can't fucking afford it.
What do you mean?
Just withdraw.
She automatically owns it.
Eddie, no, I mock you.
You know I mock you.
There's been a hundred and you literally get her out.
I mock you.
Hold on.
You don't even have money.
I'm not.
Yeah, you don't even have...
I'm withdrawing.
I'm not...
Goodbye, Killian.
It's over.
Nah, fuck off.
Your partner's put $115.
Look, Pippa, you're going to get bankrupt again.
Was the message really worth it, Pippa?
I'd like live it on the edge.
There she has the last railroad I need.
She knows she has a card.
You wasted an epic GameStop triple-A title worth of money.
She just has to be lucky and not land on anything.
Or she's fucked.
It's okay.
Chat, watch this boardwalk.
Boardwalk you gave me boardwalk Park place Park place Park
place!
Park place!
Nine?
Is that good?
Is this the third blue?
Oh!
She got her monopoly!
Oh my god!
She owns it a monopoly now!
You fucking made it!
Is this real?
She actually made it!
Wait, how do I read this?
Use something to build?
Alright, now what?
Run with color set?
Can I buy a house?
Yeah, you can.
Yeah, buy all the houses.
You press enter.
There, I go.
Press buttons.
If you get any bankrupt, it's fine.
Oh, healing?
How do I...
Here?
Let's go, dude!
Okay.
There she did it.
Now it said of $12.
Now it says $6.
We pay $12, guys.
That's right.
I have a house chat.
I own two houses.
I'm like Drake.
They're mansions.
Who is this?
Is this my- It's my railroad!
I'm safe!
First person gets me 100 bucks with a party at my place.
Oh my gosh, put it on Pippa Spa.
This is over for me.
I better not roll bad.
It's fucking over.
Yep.
We're six.
Uh-oh.
Oh, that's... Wait, that's... Is that Philly in spot?
It is!
Wait, her luck's turning around!
Oh my god, Philly in!
Her luck is finally turning around!
Wait, wait, wait, that's not my luck.
Oh, you can't afford it!
Oh my god, Pippa, baby!
I give you $8!
Pippa, I can trade with you, Pippa.
I can bail you out.
I can bail you out the exact money you need.
We'll bail you out.
Wait, no, wait, wait, wait.
Pippa, Pippa, Pippa, Pippa, Pippa.
No, Pippa, I'll give you the money back for free.
You have to go, no, please, what are you doing?
Sister, my sister in Christ.
I will give you the money.
You can kill the $24.
Just don't do it, bro.
This is fun, man.
You've doomed us all.
I'm in your stream.
She got her bell.
All I'm saying is, You requested too much from her Philly
and Philly and you requested too much from Pippa and look
what happened I gave her the money she needed I'm gonna work
with you It's gonna work with you, Pippa This is some fucked
up shit.
I'm holding on to my money.
God forbid Jesus
Hey Philly and your turn.
I need to press the button right.
Yeah, what's up chat?
All right.
Oh frick.
I need to do that.
Okay, whatever.
Uh nine I love seeing Philly and it's not good to be too
greedy.
Yeah, I win, dude.
What is this?
Oh, it's a property.
I'm hitting the oven candy chest.
What are you getting?
All right, student loans.
Student loans.
Give me student loans.
Damn, you get $50.
I bought Amazon.
What?
For 50?
You bought one stock from Amazon.
I bought a single share in Amazon.
The one stock.
This is where I die from.
Lock in, boys.
Okay, I don't die from Pippa.
Look at the barn.
I'm silent and deadly.
Who's this?
Okay, fucking money.
Thank God.
Oh, shit.
It's looming.
No, I own money.
Oh, man.
All right.
Doki.
Looming.
Doki, what do you have?
I'm the richest person here.
Or no, you're not.
It's looming.
How much do you owe again?
130?
Uh, I owe 130.
I will give you 150.
I owe you one.
Chat, check this out.
Alright, you know what?
Yeah, bail me out if I land on your fucking railroad.
I'll bail you out.
Don't worry, I'll bail you out.
Keep me out of your fucking railroad.
Give me 140.
I'm 40.
Hey, go, baby.
We got it.
We got each other.
You know, the rich has each other's back, you know?
Alliance.
Yeah.
Alright.
And then... How do we select it and then i offer i offer
wait how do i add the money i've never traded before oh wait
no what oh you want to get out of jail yeah i'll get you go
chill yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm like squidward i'm like
squidward bro nice hey hey nice nice nice nice who was it
training look at that look fillian see this is how you do
business fillian you gotta learn from the best oh my god oh
boy wait can i come to work with you you want to be an
intern yeah i'm gonna get racist yeah let me in oh oh oh
it's okay it's got no No house.
Lumi can bail you out.
She's the house.
Pippa!
Hey Pippa!
How's it coming?
What are you trading with her?
What is she having?
She's just getting money.
I don't have.
What does she have that I don't have?
I think you gotta be blonde, man.
Try and try dying your hair or something.
You demand too much, Phyllian.
That's the problem.
I told you to keep it $24 if you didn't give it a fourth
railroad.
Yeah.
one dollar in exchange for this is pissing me off
hey but she can afford a rent now did you just give her
money and then lose money or what this is we found each
other out this is how the rich stays rich this is exactly
how the rich stays rich we gotta keep the rich so rich she's
kissing your booty cheeks because she wants to be friends
with you.
That's where it is.
She's mopping the floor and sandbagging me because she knows
I'm going to keep smelling the syrup and coming back.
And she's like, keep on smashing me.
And keep on smashing me.
And she knows my entire purpose is to send her a chat and
ride her pee-pee.
She knows it.
And now she's going to do that.
And maybe I should end stream now.
What the hell are you going on about?
Wait, wait, if Philly don't stream, then the viewers will
come watch Lumia and our stream.
So like, that's...
Yeah, Philly's end stream.
No.
End stream, Philly.
Yeah, I don't feel like...
Do what you fucking want, raid me!
Raid me!
I'll lose you!
I'm back, baby!
What is that?
You're back, baby!
You're so back!
Philly, just so you know, if you raid me, I'll bail you out.
We give you offers, Philly.
I got you, I got you, Phelian.
Yeah, we got you, Phelian.
We fucking got you, man.
Did you just pay $90?
I bet you're jealous that I could do that.
Yay, where am I going?
Where's this?
Is this another chest?
I feel like I always get that on the...
Oh, this is the...
No!
I don't get my 200...
I'm too fucking rich, man!
The tax bracket!
Ratioed.
Nerd?
Tax bracket, man.
going above the tax bracket.
Oh, another double.
I might go to jail soon, guys.
She's so fucking lucky.
It doesn't even make sense.
No, guys.
If I have one more, I can't go to jail.
What do you mean?
You said, you said, Togi?
That's where you're going to be in a few minutes.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Where's that?
It's my railroad.
I get the chill.
Oh, my God.
I got the fucking chill.
You have to own half road, though.
How crazy is that?
I don't want to know.
Canadian taxes hit hard.
I don't know.
You lie on your own thing, right?
All the houses, Pippa, sells the mountain.
Oh, my God!
She said, no!
It's okay, at least you're safe now.
You know what?
This is safer.
Yeah, so you're right.
It is actually safer now.
Now you want to go to jail.
Now it's cool to go to jail.
Free woman, boy.
But she's in the rich person jail where she at.
I got a TV in here.
You know what I'm saying?
Where she's holding a man's on his jail.
It's called Champers.
It's the rich person jail where you when you get caught for
Fry is something Oh, you collect 200 That's not that's not
effing.
That's not right.
Oh my gosh.
Yes, they're 200.
Okay, can you land on my house?
No, no, no, I can land on my house.
Land on my house.
I live next door.
I'm good.
I'll pass.
Watch this.
If you need sugar, you can come over though.
Don't worry about it.
I can buy a house on Indiana Avenue.
Oh, wait, how do I?
What?
How do I buy a house?
shit man you had you can't i mean you can technically here
yeah watch oh yeah you can buy it on the light blues where
am i just keep scoring until there's a green i'm pressing
down and it's not working your honor there there you go now
i'm playing now i'm playing watch hell yeah that was just a
little i hope she rides on your square pippa that'll be the
best move if you lose if i hold on a pippa you're done it'll
be so fucking funny ah You're so lucky.
You're so lucky.
What is that?
No!
You don't even have money!
Do you want us to bail you out?
That's terrible.
Or you can mortgage your place.
You can mortgage your place.
Just mortgage.
I need an angel investor to invest in my new company idea.
I'm gonna make phase.
Give me land.
The second.
I'm gonna become phased banks.
I'm gonna kick out half my members.
I'm gonna build a new phased Philly.
I'll invest if you give me one of your properties.
Okay, that's something really You could invest in any of
your properties.
I want your I want your red property.
That's cool.
Any other offers your honor?
I want your electricity.
Okay.
Cool.
She wants to take my effing bill off of me.
That's fine.
All right.
Okay.
Well, I mean, how much you can offer for my 150.
That's what it's worth.
Oh, you're really demanding, Philly, for someone that's in
debt.
You might as well just mortgage.
Okay.
Yeah.
You might as well just mortgage if you're being very
demanding.
Are you the dog?
Kind of a choosing beggar right now.
Choosing beggar.
Put her on the subreddit.
I'm farming karma off her.
Then react.
I don't like moving over to you.
You just hover over to hover over to yourself.
To R2.
And then I'm going to be like, how do i how do i request
money oh you can like that maybe 150.
okay great so that's good good deal good deal i really like
20 on top of what you owe me you know yeah of course yeah
yeah so you're making 20 on this deal and then you give her
all i'm saying all i'm saying is that you are Fucking give
you no deal She takes back the money I have a proposal for
you Oh yeah yeah yeah I'll take What's the proposal No don't
do this to me What's the proposal Top of the portfolio You
know Proposal for doge Oh What is this proposal I've got
this electric company Yeah?
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
I heard it was owned by Philly and what happened?
And I will post a picture of you publicly online.
I heard it was owned by Philly and how did you get the
electrical company?
It is mine.
Tokyo is so interesting.
That's so funny.
I own 49%.
I put in this deal.
I told you the mortgage Philly and I told you the mortgage.
I only traded 51%.
Oh, it's my turn to go.
Yeah, it's your turn to go again.
You get to draw another dice.
How lucky are you?
Roll something else.
Okay, watch.
Boardwalk.
Double dice.
Very nice.
Oh, you're so nice.
I'm gonna watch this, Chad.
This is called the luck of the Irish.
This is called the heart of the cards.
Check me out, boys.
Oh, you get collected.
$10.
Hey, you got beauty content.
It was a beautiful film.
Nice dodge.
Chad, check my Twitter for the face reveal.
You should try Limbo next time you're streaming so we can
see how good a dodge and you are.
Yeah, yeah, I am pretty good.
Check me out.
Watch this You can roll again, by the way.
Roll again, roll again.
Oh, she's dodging.
She's fucking dodging right now.
If she hits the fucking alt.
Wait, does she get the...
Oh, it'll be so funny if she can't...
What did I get?
What?
Oh, my God.
Thanks for boarding.
Hey, thanks for like getting me this again.
I really appreciate it Yeah, you feeling so much flame on
the elbow of every joke right now
To be fair you did you sort of set yourself up to be fair
All I'm saying is that you you demanded a lot very early
game You gotta play the game.
I don't know you went in with full ego there You know what
your skin don't fit and your mother never loved you Then
we're skin so soft.
I feel like somebody's projecting right now.
Are you projecting?
Hey, look my railroad.
I always land on my railroad He always land on my own
railroad All right, Pippa, you can do it.
I don't want to get out.
Oh, maybe give me in here.
me in here it's all thank god it's fierce out there first
time the outside world is scary guys yeah it is pretty safe
over there i should head to jail all right can i can i get a
oh thank god oh what is this i would have lost
give me like the chairman i don't want to leave Come on, I
got you out of jail, Pippa.
You can come back.
No, I'm good.
It's my turn, Pippa.
It's cozy right in there.
Yeah, I'm hoping the bingo night is great.
It's more dash of charity.
It's for tax relief.
Boardwalk.
Where is this?
I don't pay tagline.
Seven's almost common number you can warn of dice.
And if I'm also going to pick your own place.
Is your safe?
I don't know.
I own this property.
You can also put more property there.
Oh.
This is what the founding...
follows intended yeah yeah just press shift you can make it
thirty dollars shift again okay now what because she has to
even out the houses yeah you have to even out the houses and
you keep going 90 bucks yeah now you have a hundred yeah
good for you wait how many properties do i own i own one
extra one it's fine okay you owe four how do i how do i help
me out for me
Okay, I feel like I might land on...
Oh, thank God.
Okay, as long as it's not Pitbull's place, that place is
scary.
You're in a row of haunted houses.
I'm fine with that.
All right, all right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is an alliance.
Yeah, this is an alliance.
We owe each other.
You know what?
I can afford.
Do I afford it?
Can you buy a house on Kentucky Avenue?
Let's see.
If I have the same set.
You know what?
Fuck it, let's do it.
I'm playing a little dangerously right now.
Mine equals controlled.
All right.
Enter.
We ashamed you landed there.
Are you enjoying jail time?
Oh, yeah.
It's very cozy.
I have a library card in here.
Oh, my God.
They're teaching her how to use a computer at the moment.
When you get out, teach me how to make moonshine.
You can become a jail lawyer.
A jail lawyer.
Yeah, you can actually be...
I learned that orange is...
a new black you become a lawyer in jail oh is this the last
pink oh that's the last pink fuck yeah phillian pippa you're
a coward what me yeah wow she insulted she was about to
offer you something phillian and then you insulted her i
don't think she's gonna offer you any more wait no i said
that pippa not loomy yeah what's your deal oh phillian yeah
i've got a deal for you Oh, yes.
Well, what is it?
Okay.
For the pink.
She doesn't have 300.
She's got a mortgage.
Yeah, she'll get there.
You got to sell her with your houses.
Wait, you're going to give me the second out of three
properties for $300.
$300.
Are you thinking I'm a brain lit?
Do you think I eat tower one for breakfast cereal?
I mean, I mean, Phyllia.
What the hell am I going to do with a second property?
But I came and paid rent on my own.
What?
$300 how would you take those and I heard that vtubers
aren't the best with financial planning so you know you ever
have the inkling if you ever have an inkling let me know let
me know oh is that my train station that's my railroad nice
nice railroad nice you're in debt good job okay he'll be
$300 what do you say I can I can give you I can give you uh
80 80 for the pink.
What happened to 300?
Yeah, well now you're kind of in a disadvantageous
situation.
Yeah, we are the deal.
What happened to 300?
I am the only one who can bail you out, Phelian.
I'm the only one who can bail you out, Phelian.
Can I saw a house?
Phelian, you can literally bail yourself out.
You can bail yourself out.
Go to the board map.
Dude, there's more buttons than trade.
Move your cursor around
You're on the blue shit But I also have one more property I
don't care about How do I sell it?
Just go go to control No you can't Okay you have to find
your That's my property Find your property Find your
property So much was mine God bless you This one I don't
even pick one One of these is mine This one You can't sell
it.
You have to mortgage it.
Oh wait.
That means that's no What are you feeling you don't have
options.
Oh, I do You either mortgage or you make a deal.
You have another IOU that won't even be enough for you.
You need 80 dollars You can mortgage two properties.
Please dude like come on man You were gonna mortgage it
anyway.
We better a lot You were gonna mortgage it anyway.
I'm gonna lose the game unless you I'm gonna get 70 of you
more give me 100 instead of 80.
you can sell your houses.
Okay, I'll give you 100.
I'll give you 100.
Thank you You can sell your houses though just so yeah, just
so you know you Lumi you gotta start leveraging tweets and
stuff you gotta you gotta you gotta tweet the Panic of
Lumi's the fucking best doing the map.
Yeah, all I'm saying Lumi is that you could have actually on
her knees right now for a bailout.
Can you stream on Twitch?
Billion's willing to do anything right now, Lumi.
You should have asked for more.
Stream on Twitch.
Deal?
I don't.
Alright, I just have to stream it.
Alright, I'll take it.
Wait, did you, what did you do?
You still don't.
She actually scammed you.
She actually...
Wait, I didn't get you the money!
Wait, sir.
I didn't get it.
Okay, I didn't hit it again.
I didn't hit okay.
Okay, I can't do that.
I'm scared of you.
And she took a property.
I'm going to take it.
All I'm saying is...
I'll give you $110 for each other.
There you go.
You didn't notice this, but she took one of your properties
too, Phyllian.
She literally took your property.
We were trading my property.
Kick her while she's down.
Just hit one.
Luby, leverage something.
Kick her while she's down.
Do it, do it, do it.
Stop, do it.
Okay, how do I...
More from her.
Good, good, good.
Yeah.
How do you accept the deal?
Deal, deal, deal.
Deal, deal.
Here's a hundred bucks.
Lumi, you coward.
You could have gotten more.
She's desperate.
How?
She doesn't even, she didn't even notice that you took her
property.
She didn't even notice.
Joki, I was gambling the property for the money, dog.
That was the entire point of the matter.
I just kind of earned money from this one.
Now we know that Philly doesn't look at what she's trading.
So now we know.
I'm in virtual reality and there's four people that can
steal my money.
I'm gonna make it up in jail.
Is this stealing if you, like, don't even pay attention?
It's not really stealing.
Okay, trick.
All right, I know.
My turn.
See, in the spirit of fairness, I need to have someone to
exploit if we're gonna keep playing.
Whoa!
Am I going to tax again?
Oh, no, I didn't.
Okay, thank God.
I was gonna say it.
I can pay it.
Yeah, I can pay $4.
It's just $4.
What's $4 between $4 and a donkey?
Yeah, see?
Let's see.
Oh, I can buy more prop.
Okay, I'm going to put it on.
Can you put a house on me?
I'm going to put it here.
Can you wizard laws me?
I want to be the foundation.
You guys hear something?
I can't hear people who has income less than $50.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Can I take a look at the porn?
Can I take a look?
That's the cry of the porn that I hear right now.
I'm rich deaf right now.
I'm starting OnlyFans
Yeah, Pippa I'm gonna out No Oh no, you're out You're out No
Yeah, Pippa Shut up, Philly Yeah, you land on the chance
Yeah, you land on the Indiana Lucky Oh, you gotta go Go Oh
Wait, you have to go to my play.
Wait, what?
How did you get here?
I didn't even pass goal.
You literally are?
Wait, how did you get to my play?
Want me?
How much do you need?
Give me a dollar.
I'll bet you love.
I'm all in chat.
I'm all in on blue.
I like how nobody's mortgaging.
Oh, I don't want some mortgage.
I don't know what that means, man.
It's when you get engaged.
I mean, women are real.
I have no idea what mortgaging is.
It's when you get engaged.
Oh.
Yeah, if you marry the dude from Rick and Morty, well, A,
you get a nothing lawsuit, but B, you get mortgaged, gauged.
Because my money's all going to Doki.
Oh, it's going back to me, right?
Oh, shit, yeah, it didn't go back to me.
Yay.
Congratulations, Doki.
I want to go to jail too I feel safer in jail now I'll give
you my pink I'll give you my pink if you give me the
electricity okay okay do you want to marry me what no of
course not marry me no print up marry me no print up marry
me no print up yeah you pay this actually I can pay me no
print up all right all right I'll do a trade I would give
you that I'll give you a monopoly give me my Uh, yeah,
fucking deal.
What the?
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
Alright, here's your monopoly.
Yay!
And then I'll...
Okay.
I'll give you this monopoly.
Hell yeah.
Philly is not okay right now.
Can you know the song on Terra Modus was discovered four
days ago and it was found even in a dome called Angel's
Thesis?
Alright, yeah.
I take that deal.
Enjoy your electricity.
I didn't need you.
those anyway it's fine i want electricity now i own the
water and the electricity
all right ninety dollars we are all so i'm saying is that
loomy's gonna win the end game because she has three
monopolies we are all she has three monopolies watch me go
even funny like i'm so funny and beyond we're gonna have a
powerful throw i can't bail anyone out anymore.
Look at that powerful throw.
Yeah.
See?
You're going to land on a Doki.
Wait, you land on a...
I'm not.
I'm 200.
Praise to seeing you in this neck of the woods.
All I'm saying is that you need a mortgage.
Nobody's bailing you out.
You want to do this to me, Lumi?
I can't.
I don't have shit, man.
Doki.
Doki, Doki, Doki.
Marry me.
Please.
I love you.
Doki, I looked at you and I realized I'm not gay.
Yeah, are you willing to sign a pre-nup?
Are you willing to sign a pre-nup?
Okay, no, but that's the thing.
Like, if it's true love, we should trust each other.
Are you willing to sign a pre-nup then?
If it's true love, you're willing to sign a pre-nup because
you're not in it for the money.
That's what pre-nups are.
You're not in it for the money, so you're willing to sign
it.
Is it really true love if we sign a pre-nup?
That just sounds like we don't even trust each other.
But if it is true love, then you're not in it for the money,
so you would willingly sign a pre-nup.
Why would we sign something to make it so official and
stingy literally just nods and love each other forever wow
you suddenly fell in love with me because you landed on my
property that's so weird yeah i just love you coincidence i
love a woman with the boardwalk so think about this dokey
bankrupt yourself a man before bankrupt yourself now but if
you did that wouldn't be gay because men kiss women bankrupt
yourself now you got a mortgage i'm not making any deals
with you fillian you did it to yourself you did this to
yourself in a different social class you're in it yeah you
can't hang out with us anymore how are you gonna get married
you can't sit in our table no deal
okay what's your deal yeah okay you're seven dollars
Give me all your property.
I'll bail you out.
Women are not a property.
I would never.
Give me one of your blue property and I'll bail you out.
That, that, that, that, that, that, those are my houses!
Or you mortgage it.
Here, Phyllian, you mortgage your property, you bail
yourself out.
You give me your blue property and I bail you out.
That one will be due.
Can I use up, up, up, down, down, left, right, circle,
square, triangle, start or not?
Just bankrupt Just mortgage It's over for you It's over for
you Just mortgage man Just mortgage What do I How do I even
sell your houses You can sell your houses Oh I can yeah you
go to your house Go to your territory stuff yeah control You
have to sell all you need $250 yeah but you sell Sell all
your houses
okay keep selling and then mortgage and then you mortgage
yeah but if she mortgages she can afford it feeling you have
to you either bank up mortgage or give me your property 70
dollars give me your property 70 dollars and give me your
property give me your property you want to get married Give
me your property.
I'd rather be a stripper.
Well, it's time to go to the strip club.
Oh, yeah.
You know what you want to do?
I'm going to lose my property now, but I'll regain it later.
All right.
Yeah.
Sure.
Watch this.
See?
I'm going to sell this for sale.
No, you mortgage it.
You don't sell it.
You mortgage it.
Or you give it to me.
And I'll bail you out.
Okay, so I need it.
How much money?
70?
I need $71.
So you mortgaged two buildings.
I sold all my buildings.
No, you mortgaged your property.
I know!
Just listen!
Nice job.
There you go.
Now you can afford it.
Wow.
Welcome to the rich side.
Now pay it all.
Yeah, to pay it all.
Now pay it up.
Okay, do you think Spongebob would be good on the way
Fansley.
I'm thinking of a sick combo right now.
Maybe it's time to go back to Fansley.
So I'm going to head to that pole.
Pippa.
No, Pippa Philly.
Why did you say Pippa?
It's just, it comes off my tongue very easily.
It's a Philly.
I'm going to pause.
I'm going to be loving this.
Pippa.
Put a pole in your, put a pole in your 3D world.
That works.
Oh yeah, put a pole in your 3D world.
Yeah.
It's my property.
Wait, what is this?
Oh my God.
She fucking owns everything.
Electricity!
That could have been you, Philly!
That could have been you!
I don't even need $14.
I feel like a trillion.
That could have been you!
I don't think Donald Trump could save me.
This is fucking Terra Clang.
Alright, I'll put another house here too.
I can afford it now.
Never go back to Illinois, everyone.
Stay away from Illinois.
First place.
Chicago isn't worth it.
Alright, nice.
I have houses there.
Alright, entered.
Oh my god.
$6 in a dream baby let's go this is so scary oh nobody owns
that was that is that the chance what the community box yes
community chance nice yeah you did and land on Loomy's place
you enhance your dog was rich holy shit she's making it hey
Phelian how are you feeling I like skittles I ran it on the
three houses Oh my god You ain't 800 dollars Yo anyone any
GG's in the chat $800 Nobody you have to bail yourself You
have to bail yourself out Jesus Christ man Jesus Yo bail
yourself now Wait I own this right I own this Yeah you own
this you can bail yourself Okay we can we can take that out
off okay wait i have 38 dollars with their name on them come
on all right i'm gonna what am i can't hear you philian no
i'll tell you what i'm saying that's gonna be secretly rich
i have 38 dollars their name on them i literally can't i
have to mortgage it fuck let's do a deal you have to
mortgage everything i don't think you can let's do a deal
jesus i don't know I don't think you can afford anything.
I don't think I can do it.
I just have to bankrupt it.
I think you have to like, okay, mortgage everything and see
what happens.
This is 80, 150.
Billion, you have nothing.
She can't do anything with your money.
She owes 800.
You're leveraging things, you know what the hell?
I can 10x you in months.
Oh, could you?
What if I sell... I can 10x you.
I'm gonna sell...
I'm not going to sell the orange.
I'm going to sell the shit.
Do you have 30?
I don't want this shitty brown one.
I need my last dollar, Chad.
That's me a million dollars.
God, what do I do?
What's the point of three monopolies when you can't fucking
sell shit?
I'm selling...
Try mortgaging everything so you can afford it because it's
800 fucking dollars.
Pippa, fuck you, man.
This is fucked up.
I don't think can you make it?
I mean, you have a lot of property.
For a dollar to Emma woman.
I need a bailout.
I need a fucking bailout.
For a dollar to Emma woman.
I can bail you out the remaining, I think.
Let me, I'm gonna sell the...
I'll give you two of my oranges.
Or 300.
You know what?
Yeah, I'll take it.
Okay, 305 because that's 800 exact.
I'll give you two of the more expensive ones.
How about that?
I'll give you these two.
I'll take it.
Wow.
even land on it how rich more than $50 can I be in the cool
kids club I have a thousand dollars in my bank account that
I'm not accessing it goes to a different school I do you
can't just raise her me for being poor yeah I mean we're all
That's how Monopoly works.
305, that's all I need.
Okay, I'll trade you for food stamps.
Come on, man.
That's what worked with me.
She's still having to hang out with the people.
All right, two, two oranges.
She's still bankrupt.
What do you mean?
I don't have a kind of soul to say.
Please, man.
Oh, my God, she's rich now.
Oh, my God.
It is exactly zero.
This is fucked up.
Oh, my God.
You know, Billion has a chance to land on Pippa Square, too.
That's the thing.
If I land on Pippa Square, I don't know.
If you land on Pippa Square, you're fucking out.
If I land on Yelp, I'm out.
Just let me be in jail.
Like, let me be in jail.
All right, you ready, chat?
Come here.
Boardwalk!
Why do you mean boardwalk?
Don't be old, say.
Yeah, I own boardwalk.
Oh, she got saved.
I'm free!
Please, money.
Yes, I'm free.
No, but you have to pay Lumi.
Thank you.
Thank you You don't even have $52 You gotta mortgage Your
last tear, your last property Pippa I'll make you love you
Alright, I'll give you the money, I'll give you the 50 Wait,
what?
Yeah, I hear you You wanna get married?
No, and you have to make a tweet No, you have to make a
tweet You add, you add Lumi, me and Doki Bird And you Fill
up the rest of the character limit with how great we are but
you have to put our ads at the end so that it'll show up on
your twitter feed yeah you have to post a tweet in our in
our discord group and then so we can approve it and make
edits if we need to and you can tweet it out okay okay okay
give me one sec here i'm in the tweet billion how much are
you gonna give me And you have to pin the tweet for at least
a week.
I don't want to pin it.
A hundred bucks is so worth it.
And you have to pin it for at least a week.
That's what your dignity is worth.
Yeah, yeah.
That's your dignity.
Yeah, $100.
You hear that chat?
One Akasupa is worth one billion.
I would never eat a tomato.
I would never Alex Jones.
I love blonde people.
Wait, no, I should do I should do Doki first of course, of
course, right?
Pippa first.
At Pippa.
At Doki Bird.
Okay.
At what's on his Twitter?
What's the loop?
I don't know.
I'm gonna pack Luminosity Gaming.
Alright, I'm gonna pack Luminosity Gaming.
Alright.
I would die on a sword for you.
Guys, I would give you my brain trance.
plant parentheses with your consent I am nothing but a simp
on the track
all I'm saying is that there's apparently a timer so like if
you run out of time you don't even get this deal I put it in
the group game I put in the group game I put in the group
game you got it You gotta type the right ad, man!
What is your ad?
What?
He gave me!
No deal, no deal!
You gotta edit it.
This is exactly why I had her write it in our group chat
first before she tweets it out.
Are you winning Kaneko or what?
What is your game on Twitter, dog?
I think it's Conoco underscore Loomy.
I think.
You think?
Conoco underscore Loomy.
Just copy it in.
Edit your tweet.
Okay.
I believe in you.
You got this.
I did.
I did okay wait here I'll post in again here all right all
right all right yeah there you go There you're gonna tweet
that and then you gotta make sure that you pin that tweet
for at least a week Yeah, yeah Yeah a week that's how much a
hundred dollars.
Yeah, oh that's your worst is that not your worth billion
Bro it's like animal farm everyone's or you go bankrupt now
you go bankrupt now You can't be serious dude
It's just what you want!
It's just what you love for me!
Alright, Phelian, just press enter.
We're waiting for you to accept the deal.
I want you guys to say sorry.
Why?
And what do we do?
It's just business.
She bailed you out.
Yeah, she bailed you out.
You gotta say thank you to Pippa.
You gotta say thank you, Pippa.
You gotta say thank you, Pippa, for bailing me out.
I'm so...
My life is in your debt, Pippa.
You gotta say that to her.
She literally bailed you out.
She noticed.
I was hoping you would notice it.
You didn't fucking see it.
Stitch!
You're gonna make me embarrass myself like an effing rich
person playing squid game.
And then when I'm up and done, you're gonna trim my armor?
Who do you think I am?
I'm pretty sure somebody must have read it out in their
chat.
noticed it herself.
There's no one.
I learned from my mistakes.
I didn't take this junk out.
I don't even know what it is.
All right, how do you take this junk out?
No!
You press enter.
No, no, no.
Enter?
Okay.
You press space and enter.
Oh, wait.
Oh my god.
Oh, million!
Thank you all.
Billion!
Pippa.
Oh, Pippa!
Oh, no.
But treat me my property back.
I'm gonna delete the tweet.
Treat me my property back.
Treat me back or I delete the tweet.
If you delete the tweet, I'll never bail you out again.
I'll never bail you out again.
No, no.
Give me my property back.
I will never bail you out.
No, my honors- I will never bail you out.
It has 1,000 likes in one minute.
Please do it.
I'm getting moles on Twitter in a negative way.
Pippa, please.
Trey me.
Any publicity is good publicity, Phyllian.
That's not!
No!
I don't call it Amy Shrewd ever!
I'm gonna delete the tweet!
It's the art of the fucking deal, Phyllian.
P-P-P-P-Pipa!
P-Pipa!
P-Pipa, you literally have an advantage over her.
She's like banking on her knees.
You can ask for anything from her now.
Pippa.
Any ideas?
Give me my property back.
I'm not kidding.
The adults are talking, Phyllian.
Yeah, the adults are talking.
I'm going to delete the tweet.
What do you think?
You gotta ask her to do something embarrassing now.
I'm going to delete the tweet.
If you delete the tweet, we're never bailing you out on
Monopoly.
I'd rather die than not.
I'm not going to go out on a scam.
I'm not going out on a scam.
So you'd rather be the first one to lose in Monopoly?
Yes.
You'd rather be the loser?
The first one to lose?
Okay.
You know what?
Maybe I don't, but if I doesn't change How I feel on the
inside Four of us, you would want me Okay, just tell me the
advice Talk, talk, talk, talk Just effing talk It's at 1,500
likes, thanks guys At the VTuber Awards, can you say You're
the loser at Monopoly?
Oh my bad, sorry, it's at 2,000 likes, I lied, like At the
next VTuber Awards, just say The loser at Monopoly on VTuber
Awards Yeah, and we'll bail you out We'll trade you But
we'll trade you back to property At the VTuber Awards, you
say I am bad at Monopoly.
Add the VTuber Awards.
You have to be like, I'm terrible at Monopoly.
And we will trade the...
Pippos will trade back to territory.
No, I want something I can do right now.
No, we will have an IOU.
We'll just have an IOU for the VTuber Awards.
Give me something I can do right now.
What's the most embarrassing thing you can possibly do?
I'll probably delete a tweet.
No.
Make the tweet your banner.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, true.
Word copper.
You would do this today?
Make a tweet your Twitter banner and your YouTube channel
banner because it has two million subscribers.
She has more people on her YouTube channel than her Twitter.
So she should make a banner on her YouTube channel.
No, no, no, no.
You do better.
I don't do it.
You get the territory back.
You get your property back.
No, I'll just leave.
I'll just lose monopoly.
That's fine.
I'll delete the whole of your tweet.
You just, you're right on this monopolis.
Like it's, it's Million, it's such a small thing.
I'm gonna end stream on the radio.
It's just a small thing.
Million, why are you letting Monopolis get to you?
Well, he just made it my Twitter banner.
Because at least can, like, take the plate on one platform.
On the Twitter banner?
Okay, nice, all right, sure.
And Twitter banner.
Wow, now I just negotiate myself backwards.
negotiating work you know how negotiating work you give a
long tall order so they'll want you to do you do what the
hell is this okay whatever that's not negotiating works you
give a very big demand and then it'll make them want to do
the letter demand because you weren't going to do the
twitter thing at first all right twitter banner now i am
hard on the deal baby i'm not Nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah.
Okay, edit profile, change my effing banner downwards.
This is so dumb.
The best trade girl in this story.
If you follow my Twitter, it'll be the same.
Hey, look, we're getting it.
I'm just putting my blog down, my profile finger stuck in
the middle of my face.
All right, great.
Are we done?
Yep.
Yeah, Pivot just give me my helping property back.
Just pay for it a $52 so we can trade Hit the pay.
Yeah, pay first Pivot, please give my property back.
Press it on.
Press it.
Okay, okay.
You do it for me.
I don't want to do this.
Oh, you.
Oh my god.
Yes
And then you have to ask for a little give a little bit of
money Okay, I'll give a dollar Okay, all right, there you go
great That is you No, it's not a headspace Hit enter, hit
enter I accept I'm deleting the tweet No, no, you You said a
week You said a week I did that but now Well, guess what?
Who's gonna stop me now?
Who won't stop me?
What is it?
A fussy?
Philly was a scabbler all along.
We were making business negotiations with Philly.
I know, I'm getting scabbling.
I don't get to talk while these guys are talking.
You sit at the kids' table, Philly.
I took them to the preschool all over again.
Philly and our fucking zoo pals place.
My face is so familiar with the inside of a toilet from the
number of strolls I've gotten.
Please stop me on this property.
Jesus.
No honor.
No honor, man.
I think Pippa's gonna win this in the end.
Her property is scary.
I don't know.
It's between us.
Oh my god, boardwalk.
Hey, $50.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine?
Yeah, that's the money.
Hey, Philly, and remember when you landed on boardwalk?
Yeah, remember that?
That was so funny.
That's the place you've always wanted.
I should have been paying you $50.
Can I get in jail, please?
Yeah, I want to go to jail.
I want jail.
Give me jail.
I don't want to be here anymore.
Oh, you got that!
Oh, you can't afford it!
Jesus.
But Pippa can.
I'm just fucking withdrawing.
There you go.
Enjoy your property.
I don't know what you expect.
Philly is.
Nice try.
You have to withdraw.
I rest my case, Romney.
1-21.
This is horrifying.
This whole game's fucked up.
I'll enter.
Just let me fast go.
Okay.
We're at the stage where it's like, it's the final
countdown.
Let's go.
Get bankrupt first.
Waited for death.
You have to pay $100.
You don't have money, by the way.
You don't have...
I love your eye life.
You really have...
What tweet do you guys want?
Just mortgage.
You have one more property to mortgage.
I know.
I can tweet, too.
Well, we know you're going to delete the tweet.
This is how you get addicted to drugs, no?
It's like, yeah, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I can just sell off a body part.
Just give me a little...
One hit.
The thing is, we can't trust you anymore because you said
you delete tweets.
So we can't trust you about tweets anymore.
Kind of a sore loser, Philly.
You are making me kick.
You are evicting me from my home.
Just so you know.
We are evicting a VTuber.
Your arrogance did this.
Yeah, your arrogance did this.
What do you mean?
Biblically accurate Elden Ring characters?
What is this?
The price of your Elden Ring is billion.
She's fallen.
Okay, like, what is this?
You don't even pay it to, like, us.
Yeah, you pay it to, like, the government.
the government I am not a fan of the government the past go
oh my turn I think I might I might have the mortgage soon I
don't think I'm gonna survive and Pippa's fucking scary
apparently the face next CEO saw my tweet okay okay yo can I
join face can you give me a thousand bucks a You bail her
out.
Billion, I'll give you 500.
You joined Faze.
Yeah, I'm going Corpo.
Show me that go well wrong.
Alright, like...
I'll give you a...
You're gonna be 500 if I join?
Yeah.
Okay, okay, sweet.
I'm in.
Okay.
I'll join?
And then we won't sign a prenup.
What?
Why would you just sign a prenup for Faze Clan?
I'm getting married.
Wait, okay, so be honest, do you have independence or not?
Independence?
Like, what do you mean?
Can you make a pen dance?
What?
Do you have independence?
It's hard to keep off of this.
Pippa, Pippa, I'll give you a get-out-of-jail-free card for
one of the, for the last blue.
Sounds good.
Let's do it.
This is fucked up, man.
This is fucked up.
Tray the Get Out of Jail free card?
Yeah, you can.
You can.
Yeah.
Future is now old, man.
And then I will take the blue.
Wait, Pippa, why would you...
Don't you want to be in jail?
But she can pretend she can get out, but she wouldn't.
It's a choice.
She doesn't have to use it.
This is literally collusion.
Pippa, you think this is going to get you somewhere?
She doesn't have to use it.
Where are you, Pippa?
I'm in the middle of the house.
What do you mean?
You're in the middle of the house.
I'm sorry to be on my board right now.
Oh my god.
It's your fault I'm broke.
What?
Now you're blaming others.
The corruption is insane, man.
What the hell?
You made your bed, Philean.
VTuber doesn't take responsibility.
I never did.
I never will.
My bed bugs pay rent.
Yeah.
Doesn't look like it.
Oh, she got some jail.
God, she got the best card!
Hey, Pippa!
Why don't you use it?
Get out of jail, Pippa.
Why don't you get out of jail, Pippa?
Come on.
Do it.
I mean, I can with the card I just got that you made fun of
me to get in.
You're gonna.
Look at that.
I know you are.
Because you want to get out of jail.
I know you do.
Please let me out of jail.
Let me in jail.
What is that?
This game.
Let's see.
Oh, it's so close.
Oh, my God!
It's taxed.
You got taxed.
I'm so fucked up!
Oh my god!
Loomy stealing from the self-checkout, hoping to catch her.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what you get.
I put those gummy bears in my pocket, so what?
Oh my god, it would be so funny if she has to pay the
government tax too.
What is that?
That's eight.
That's a lot of numbers.
Oh, hey, it's your own property!
You got saved!
Yeah!
No, no, she mortgaged it, didn't she?
Yeah, she mortgaged it, but...
But she can't do anything with it.
Can't do it.
No, I can buy a house.
I mean, you can, yeah.
I'll do it.
Wait, what does mortgaging do again?
The other spaces, you don't pay anything on the other
spaces.
Oh.
So, like, if we landed on her other two squares that she
mortgaged, then we don't have to pay her anything.
Okay, so I have a spot again.
I have a spot again.
No, you don't because you're still mortgaging that spot.
I bought it.
I just bought it back.
I just bought it.
Wait, you don't.
I unmortgage.
You don't.
I own a mortgage!
Oh my god, $50!
I own a property!
$50 is better than $800.
I'll take it.
Slowly, but surely.
As long as we have to pip us.
I own a property.
I'm not a property owner.
Dude, I'm one of the elites.
So guys, do you know how I get pizza this Saturday?
You guys want to have like a pizza party or?
Pizza party.
We want money.
I have a house.
We can crash.
in my place can you afford pizza right now
scavenging from the table yeah that's it it's like it's like
hey pippa nice to see you hi good to see you too she's in
the lab we're learning to be a lawyer yeah it's gonna be a
jail lawyer how do you yes just learn so far whoa who's boy
Oh, no.
That's...
It's fine.
It's like $5.
It's okay.
It's mortgage.
It's like...
Yeah.
It's mortgage.
So you're fine.
You got saved.
Can I borrow you?
No.
You actually got saved.
I think Loomy can un-mortgage this soon.
I think I can if I get close.
Wait, can I un-mortgage my property?
You can if you have the money, yeah.
Why am I not doing that then?
Well, I don't fucking know.
That's yours.
choice
All right, what's the proposal I'll give it to for 80 bucks
for 80 bucks.
I'll take it 80 bucks Yeah, you know what fuck it anyone
want to go on a walk.
It's free
We can steal this off from the park.
All right.
I will give you a full monopoly.
I'll take it.
That sounds like a good deal.
Yep.
Wait, that's mine.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
I know that has you.
Yeah, yeah.
No, no, no.
That's right.
Yeah, that's right.
All right.
Here we go.
Except.
Nice deal.
Cool $80.
I'm just struggling to live, okay?
After people bankrupted me.
Look at this bitch and now she's hiding in jail.
That's how the rich survive.
She doesn't have to pay taxes because she's in jail.
Yeah, she doesn't have to do shit.
She just sits in jail and chills.
Legally, I have no income.
You're AFK.
You're having AFK.
I hate this game.
You chose it.
I want to be in jail.
You did choose it.
You did.
Oh, you get to have your...
Yeah, you just have to look through your properties.
You guys made me tweet about it.
All right, end turn.
Right?
That's it.
Does that mean Philean's got to pay me?
No, she has to land on it again.
No, it is your turn.
What do you mean, Philean?
Roll it too, Philean.
Roll it too.
And it's my property.
What is that?
That's like, that's one of my trades.
Stop.
You can't even up.
Guys, it's time to mortgage again.
Philly, it's time to mortgage.
Okay, that's fine.
I'll mortgage.
Got back, and then Gordon.
Okay, that's fine.
She can't even afford it with a mortgage.
Can I, can I, can anyone?
You just need like...
I have a gun.
Yeah?
No, I want to trade.
I'm gonna trade with Pippa.
You only need $58.
Who wants to trade me?
What's $58 worth you, Philean?
Um, God, at least one kidney.
Maybe even a contact bar?
Give us one of your blues.
Okay.
All right.
That's fine.
Oh, my God.
Pippa, take it.
Take the blue.
Take one of the blue.
You could sell some feet pigs right now on the internet.
Okay.
Wait, does she have a blue?
Yeah, take her out of her light blue so she doesn't have her
monopoly.
anymore she's that desperate I'll trade with you I'll trade
with you for that blue property no pipo yeah six dollars for
content reasons what content reasons content reasons I'm
mainstream I'm an extreme please I come to you a humble
traveler Uh-huh.
How humble.
Like, I'll give you a dollar?
Denigrate yourself.
I will give you a dollar.
You will give me...
At least three dollars.
I love this.
You can't afford- You can't afford the- I was gonna say not
three dollars.
And now we can be best friends forever.
Final offer.
Take your blues.
Pippa, you know you want to.
Wait, how do I add the money?
Yeah.
Okay, and now I- how do I hear?
Okay.
There it is.
Deal.
All right.
I'm supposed to- So, like, you know, like, we've been
through a lot back in our day and I just wanted to say,
like, your hair is just so effing nice and- Yeah.
Some days I dream about, like, a white Christmas when I- I-
I- I- where I- I- Uh-huh.
Oh, I'm lagging.
Yeah.
Yeah, but how about this?
I'll impress you.
Sticking out your gut for the Rizzler.
I'm not impressed.
You have to ask for two properties because she did that.
I'm trying.
Can you?
I'll sweeten the deal a bit.
Bro, you must have declared bankruptcy.
This is not worth it.
You just declared bankruptcy.
You practically lost everything.
even have anything anymore after you do this deal.
Fillian, think of your dignity, Fillian.
Fillian, just declare bankruptcy.
You basically lose.
Fillian, it's good content, alright?
Give me everything you own.
It's made content!
Think of it this way.
If you declare...
Oh my god.
The mortgage was only $66.
That's so serious.
sad
Holy shit, bro.
Thank you Philean.
I think Pippa's gonna win.
There's no way There's no way she lose Was it worth it
Philean?
She's practically like homeless Bro Philean's like I'm
talking about pack of flamingos Bro Philean's just homeless
now.
She owns nothing thing that's actually crazy yeah what house
so my house is close to renovating we're renovating it we're
renovating it we're renovating it we're renovating it yeah
how's that going for you yay thank god it got mortgaged holy
shit Oh Bro, I'm deflated that whole avenue is fucked up I
know that whole side of the board this whole side Fucking
land on there man.
This whole side is scary.
Oh, no I fucking hate that Yeah, I wish I was in jail too I
wish I was in jail He could just...
Oh, wow.
He could just gain money.
No, you have to pay 50 now.
Oh.
Yeah, or you used to get a free jail card.
Yeah.
Good trade, don't you?
Good trade.
Yeah.
All right, all right.
Nice, nice.
Thanks, people.
Thank you.
It's just $14.
That's just...
I remember when I, like, hopes and dreams in a family and
children and prospects and, like, I'm like, at least $16 in
my bank account.
That was cool.
Yeah, no, it's not 16.
You have 241.
Oh.
Look at that thing.
With this money, I summon a victory In like 10 minutes Yeah
Where the property's still around I don't think Just give me
off the death lane Okay, does anyone want to Give me off
this shit Fuck Okay, I'm an avian At least it's dying Oh my
gosh Oh my gosh Doki, you want a monopoly?
Hell yeah Hey Doki I'll get that monopoly Look at this I can
win this chat Oh, I can win this Philly and me Oh, 250?
Okay, okay, okay I can win this I can win this Yeah, dokey.
I've got this one property.
I'm gonna make a lemonade.
Yeah, I'll take it.
Yeah, and then I'll bail you out.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I'm gonna make how much do you need?
I think I need 140.
All right, I'll bail you out 140 that's how monopoly usually
rolls at the end.
You know what I'll give you 145 because I feel generous.
I'll take it I'll take it.
She's so generous.
I feel so generous.
There we go.
She's literally so fucking generous.
All right.
Enjoy your monopoly.
Just end the stream.
Alright, chat.
Just fucking give up, man.
Yeah, and I get my money back, so I got it for free.
It's not over until I actually got the orange for free.
Holy shit.
Can I go to jail, please?
It's not over until I actually lose chat.
Jail me.
so many crimes i'm a bad person i deserve it what is that oh
good oh that's mine that's my what is that that's my water
it's only 40.
what if i just don't shower wait if both utilities are owned
rent is 10 times the amount shown on the dice oh not bad not
bad what if i just What if what if I just don't shower?
Not bad.
Yeah?
Doki, doki, doki, doki.
I'm literally on my last effing...
You're not even using...
You need why.
You have $240.
Yeah, you have $240.
You're still alive.
I can hear her like text a speech in the background.
Did you hear that?
Did you guys hear that?
Shut up.
You can't get your chat to bail you out, Philly.
I can't bail you out, man.
Yeah, this is so sad.
Can we get like five subs?
Yeah, five subs at Doki Bird at Twitch.
How did I get reduced to a sim?
I just do money by pay people as I walk around.
I'm a little pay pig.
Yeah.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Some people are like that.
Oh, you're right.
Can you put that on YouTube next time you need a bailout?
Just oink, oink a little bit?
Yeah, just oink for a chance.
I love that.
Sorry.
I'm just getting sober.
I own this.
you know I'm gonna go put a house where's Phelion where is
she there she is okay what is her closest property right now
let's see I'm gonna put I'm gonna put a house here too let's
see put it on boardwalk put it on boardwalk yeah put it on
boardwalk you know I'll put it on boardwalk I'll put it on
boardwalk for you that's my final destination I'm gonna go
to boardwalk I'm gonna an effing die all right take life
insurance okay all right seven oh hey oh my god that's mine
oh everything is yours oh you gotta sell you gotta sell i'm
700 now
deal here.
We can make a deal, yes?
Even if she trades her entire life savings, like, she won't.
What?
Oh, you're going to give me one card back.
Out of the deal, baby.
Out of the deal.
Don't you want your... Don't insult me.
Oh, you want to insult me.
Yeah, don't you want to negotiate?
Wait, you are insulting me.
You're taking more than I...
I sold that for like seven bucks.
You can have a house, Phyllian.
pebble i don't think you're gonna negotiate with me i'm kind
of rich and you're not so yeah how about i say final offers
nope nope not final you don't have anything you don't own
anything felly i'm just taking i know but if i own one
property that generates eight dollars it's not gonna get me
anywhere eight dollars is more than zero i like you make a
counter offer zero i like you make a counter offer but i'm
done okay How can you counter-offer that you don't own
anything?
No, let's pay this turn to counter-offer.
No!
I don't think you know the rules of the game.
How do I do this?
Here?
There.
I'm thinking more like this.
Exactly.
What?
Wait, how am I still offering 150?
I refuse.
And then we refuse.
All right, good luck.
What?
Philly, you will regret this.
Yeah, but my peers already didn't regret.
Oh, shit.
You made an enemy.
I made an enemy.
Shut up.
I have no dollars.
I have no property.
I have no hoes.
My wife led me for Andrew Tate and my Bugatti got impounded.
How do you want me to win this?
I'm not going to live there.
Your wife left you for me.
I'm in San Francisco.
Poopy on the floor right now.
Stop laughing.
Add it to the poop map.
Put it on the poop map.
That's Phyllians.
We'll put a little star on it.
It'll be like the Hollywood Walk of Fame except Phyllians
poop.
What?
Oh my god.
The board is more free now.
The board is more generous.
You're gonna make it!
Sell your homes, Pippa!
You have to sell!
You don't need the yacht, Pippa!
Sell it!
Just sell until you need $100 and then ask for a fill-in for
$100.
Pippa, I'll do the deal for $100.
Can you sell her one of her own mortgage like properties and
then she can't even use it?
That's true!
Sell the blues because she can't even pay I can't even pay
back the mortgages!
I can't even pay back the mortgages!
You sell the blues!
I can't even fucking mortgages!
You can't un-mortgages!
You're so smart!
My god, I'll hear billion.
All of them!
What?
There you go.
There's a deal.
All her money, all her money.
She'll take it.
She'll give her some properties!
Can I take all her money?
What?
What is happening?
Billion, I'm giving you a monopoly.
Yeah, we just want all your money.
I'll leave you $1.
What?
Yeah, that's so cheap, Billion.
It's so cheap, what a deal.
It's like a bargain bin deal.
$150.
Hmm?
Billion, you're literally gonna get back your monopoly.
Just take away one of the cards.
I said $150.
How about $170?
100 160 160 see this is how you negotiate okay did i do it
yeah do it do it 120 value that's like half the value half
off by everyone free all you people there it is chat see now
we're back chat now we're back he can't even take any of the
money you
gotta pay to pay the big six dollars each I don't get it but
it's not bad there you go I was gonna I was gonna set up I
just literally she gave me more money that's $60 that's $55
wait a second oh wait no it's not oh no it's not wait no I
can sell it no it's already mortgage but you got your
property back Phelan yeah yay You got your property back!
Oh my god!
It's so hard!
Jesus!
Jesus fucking Christ!
I'll give you, yeah, Libby, I'll keep you in the game,
Libby.
I'll keep you in the game, Libby.
Okay, do, okay, I'll give you the full Monopoly bag.
Fuck!
Fuck, man!
I'm fucking over!
You need, you need a...
I need a fella!
I'll keep you in, don't worry!
Jesus!
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god.
If Doki maybe lands on Pippa's, maybe it'll work?
Chad, the street probably accurate.
Thank you.
Alright, here we go.
Don't worry, I got you.
Got you.
69.
Nice.
There you go.
I'm gonna cry.
I own a monopoly.
Oh my god.
Alright, you know what?
I will...
I'll repay this mortgage.
Jesus, look at her board.
She's got like everything.
Holy Holy shit.
You're living by the thread with one dollar.
Just watch out.
Watch out.
Please, please, please, please.
Please, please, please.
Please, please.
Watch out.
The one dollar.
You.
Me.
Does anyone want to let me sexually assault them?
I mean, if you get two, if you get two, you'll be fine.
If you get two.
Please, let me sexually assault someone.
Boardwalk.
This is over.
No, you're not.
You're so fine.
Yeah, community chest.
Yeah!
Wow, American healthcare is what's gonna do me in, huh?
American healthcare.
That's what does me in.
I think you just got to kill your bankruptcy, or you can
sell your...
You can... Well, you already mortgaged it, so I can bail you
out.
all your blues i paid 150 for them 60.
i can bail you out if you give me all your blues or declare
bankruptcy now if i declare bankruptcy do i lose yes you'll
be the first one to lose you're telling me the american
healthcare system is too immune i'm offering you a bailout
yeah i'm literally giving you a great deal Yo, Pippa, you
want the- She can't afford to sell you out.
Well, I don't have nothing.
She can't afford it.
You have $41.
Yeah?
So, trade me for $25.
Yeah, we're like it.
You can take the blue property.
I don't want the blue property.
I have to pay the mortgage.
It's not as funny.
Oh my god I won all three I won all three No deal, just lose
the game You know what, you know what?
Freak you Just lose the game No deal No deal Chill, chill,
chill, chill Chill, chill, chill, chill Okay Give me all of
it Okay
How do I...
What am I doing?
Are you okay?
Oh no, her mouse doesn't work all of a sudden!
Oh wow, the moment you had to give me all of it.
There we go.
Oh my fucking god.
Just so you know, this is worth more than you are.
Someone's just freaking...
Someone's salty that they're losing in Monopoly.
That's so sad.
I'm having all the pain.
Hey, you can pay for your health insurance now.
Is that great?
That's what pay off all these mortgages.
Yeah.
Now you just have to pay for the healthcare.
Chat, I'm literally one.
It's okay, you're so close to the end.
All you gotta do is land on boardwalk, grab your toaster,
and you're done.
Yeah.
Chat, I'm literally one.
And your turn.
It's my turn now.
I got one, chat.
I'm going to land on, like, Like Pippa Square, I feel like.
Oh, and less.
Oh, shit.
This luck is insane.
Chance.
This luck is literally insane.
Hello.
Take a treat.
Oh.
I'm going to go to my own railroad?
What the?
Let's go.
I'm like a protagonist and a hentai.
I'm just happy to be in jail, man.
All I ever wanted was to be in jail.
Wait, is that?
That's...
Oh, oh.
Whoa.
It's so jucky.
You own this.
You're so safe.
I gotta roll again, though.
Yeah, you gotta roll again.
Where's that?
What is that?
I don't know.
I'm scared.
Nobody has any money.
Who is that?
Oh, you got chance.
Oh, you're safe.
You're safe.
Thread the needle.
You threaded the needle.
Go back three spaces.
Oh, my God.
Now you can be.
There's nothing I could have done.
Come on, come on, come on.
And you get money!
At least I'm not Philean.
She's still in this.
I was in jail for one turn, dude.
I was in jail for one turn.
I think Philean's coping right now.
She's going through it.
Oh, you got out!
One time you don't want to get out.
And that's the property you sold me.
I'll bail you out.
Don't worry.
I won't make you the last Fill you up What am I even doing
anymore, dude?
What am I even doing anymore?
I'll give you my last fucking dollar Yeah There's no problem
Fill you up, no problem, bro I'm just like How much do you
need?
I think I need, just 30 is fine 30, I'm just a starving
fillian, dude Jesus fucking Christ, man I'm supposed to die
I'm about to die I'm the dollar Jail Lumi Lumi Can you trade
me a dollar Please I just want to buy a big Mac Lumi Let me
buy a big Mac I'll be the bail Out of the government And
you're the bank I'll do bail You need the dollar I was
supposed to be safe in jail Fuck my money You and you're
zero dollars No Boardwalk Okay so what's safe Boardwalk What
Boardwalk For you, nothing is safe.
A six or an eight.
What did I say?
Just chat.
Roll the dice.
Hard of the dice.
Right.
Hard of the dice, baby.
Blow on them.
We believe in you.
Boardwalk.
The fuck up.
Oh.
Not boardwalk.
That's a good number.
That's a good number, right?
Yay!
You just did the same.
Let's go!
Go!
God, she's safe for another turn.
She's safe again.
Safe for now.
Oh, hey, this is...
Look at this property.
My beauty heart.
Which is, like, the closest.
Okay, Phileon's close to here, so I'll put...
I'm buying a water ticket.
I'm going to...
All right.
Oh, my God.
You're going to build a house on my property.
That's my money.
Your property?
That's my...
We're proud.
You build a more old city, and you have more fans there than
I do.
I'm getting more like Drake versus Kendrick.
Like, it's just...
Okay.
Good luck.
I hope you don't land there.
Listen, listen, listen, don't you...
I know how this junk works, okay?
I literally had a house there.
If you land on that, I will owe you, like, $14.
I don't go for free.
Pippa!
Oh!
Oh, no.
Pippa, oh, my God.
Pippa, I'll bail you out.
Or you can sell your mortgage, your property.
You can pick.
Yeah, mortgage, your belt.
It's time to fuck off.
Mortgage your belt.
I'll give you an IOU.
Okay, and I'll take it.
I'll take it.
Can't put it to the last one in.
I have $200.
I can't die before Philean.
Yeah, and nothing to offer.
I have a lot of assets.
Emma Baker?
You have nothing to do.
I got an action zero.
This is action three one.
What do you mean?
I'm just bailing people out.
Well, you know what, brother?
I'm not being tortured.
You know what?
I'm what I want.
This is so stupid.
I'm bailing people out.
I'm like, you're going to bail me out.
You build a house on blue.
I've bailed you out.
I gave you the option to get bail out.
You didn't take it.
I gave you that option.
I gave you my property.
I gave you the property.
I gave you.
I pulled a hat on her specifically because I was gonna buy
it and now I'm feeling it.
I'll feel you out of it.
You are an epic liar!
You were jesting!
I'm in the death zone!
I'm becoming atheists!
You're fine.
You got the... You got the...
You got the save.
It's okay.
You're a Fortnite 2018 great pistol.
Chance, chance, chance, chance!
Oh, now dodge.
If unowned...
and pay over.
Oh, that's my utility.
Ten times?
Yeah, it's me.
Sheez.
Goodbye, cool world.
Hey, you got a spare home shop.
Yeah, I can fill you up.
Don't worry.
I can fill you up.
Just before, just, just until Philly and dies, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course, of course.
Just all I need.
All I need to live, well, just gotta live until Philly and
dies.
No, chat, me, my clubs are real.
How much do you need?
90 90 okay don't worry i've got you don't you we're
independent vtubers don't let these corpus bosses around
this is money for you stand up for yourself all for you come
on dude my wallet exactly don't worry i got you guys all
right thank you thank you all right still not dead
Are you going back to jail, please?
This is unbelievable.
Let me go back to jail, please.
Just let me end it all.
Fuck.
Doki, independent VTubers strong together.
No, you're a part of Mythic.
Wardwalk!
Oh, it might actually be, you know?
Oh, shit.
She's a duo.
Oh, she's just missing.
She avoids me.
She avoids it yet again.
Okay, so I'm gonna go over after I walk you up.
Okay, I'm gonna go over to security guard and twerk him.
They don't put me in jail.
They're racist.
That's my plan of action.
She gets to avoid jail again again.
I'm gonna go in there.
Oh, is that Pippa's?
No, that's mine.
Oh, thank God.
That's mine.
Oh, no.
Everything milky.
Oh, yeah, I do.
You want the entire side of the board.
Oh, my God.
I do.
Where is she going?
Okay, I'm gonna put a house here.
What are you doing?
Actually, I'm gonna put a house.
Actually, I'll put a house here.
She might land on here more often.
Am I in the Middle East?
Every step is a land This is ridiculous I'm going to put it
here And then I'm going to put one here as well And then
here as well Good luck Good luck Philly In Good luck Good
luck I believe in you Philly Then I believe in you I'm going
to do it Drop my turn Turn my turn Four Three Three Hey
you're fine Like me Yeah Hey Look at that!
She's alive!
For now.
Hey!
You get another bell out!
Look at you!
Making it!
Please let me just go to jail.
Please let me go to jail.
Please, please, Snake Eyes, Snake Eyes, Snake Eyes.
Come on, Snake Eyes.
Oh, you get a community chest!
Okay, please let me live.
Please let me live.
Yes!
Holy shit, we're still in it.
It's a 4v1.
Good luck, Bill.
I own this entire side, so good luck.
Just so you know, I actually got dragged into the military,
so I actually have to go.
Oh, so you're declaring bankruptcy?
You're going to declare bankruptcy?
No, no, no, no.
Well, you have to leave.
If you have to leave.
Forward walk!
What's up, eventually?
See?
Easy.
It's really nice knowing that it's not the place I just
bought the house on.
Like, I literally just got bought the house.
That's crazy.
Oh, it's not so bad.
It's not so bad.
so bad.
I just put one house there.
Look at that.
It's like a rat, and it cannot be that bad.
It's not that bad, see?
She's so happy.
And turn for me.
Okay, sure.
She's fucking disabled.
You're taking everything from, you must take my epic turn.
Oh, Deppin!
Let's go.
I'm gonna take my epic organs.
You're like, yay!
And then I can roll again.
Let's go Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
The luck on this girl is insane.
I think this game would have ended This is unreal.
I think this is is that your is that mine or yours.
Oh, it's I get to go to jail Oh my god.
Oh my god.
I get to go to jail She's a good person let her out.
She doesn't deserve jail She deserves your reputation is a
bit now, Doki.
No, it's fine.
I'm fine with being.
It's okay.
Yeah, you're a criminal.
I'm here to reform.
She's got delicate skin and stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
I got framed, guys.
It's okay.
I got framed.
Look, I haven't...
It was so unfortunate to get framed like that.
All right.
How did she owe $20, but I owe 70?
Because I have a house on that property, Philean.
That's so crazy.
How did that happen?
Phelian, if you'd been a nicer person.
Yeah, you'd been a nicer person at the beginning of the
game.
Am I dead?
Am I done?
Oh, my God.
It's not over yet.
I'll take that.
I don't care.
It's not boardwalk.
I'm free.
All right, Phelian.
Good luck.
I own half of that side as well.
That's Death Row, right?
That's it.
Eight!
Oh, eight.
That's...
How many houses is that?
That's like more than one.
Fillion, I think it's time.
You don't have anything left.
Fillion?
Wait, you actually don't have anything.
Fillion.
I'm not bailing you out.
There's no bail out here, Fillion.
What?
It's better on the other side.
Check this one.
I said go into the light Just accepted Philly Just end this
already Like the rope store is on that street Don't wait
Just end it I said check discord Just end it Check discord
I'll have to do it I'll have to do it Or this is Pippa's
choice because she got this is Pippa's choice Either we make
Philly and lose first now Wait, wait, Keith.
Phelan, I'll bail you out.
But you have to give me something.
What does she have?
You want my effing fridge?
Not much.
Okay.
Let's see.
I don't know.
Start offering stuff, actually.
You're the one who needs me.
Okay, I'll tell you a joke.
No, I don't want a joke.
Your jokes are bad.
What does it mean?
You want a brick wall.
Nope.
A brick gets laid first.
Not laughing.
Not funny.
Uh-huh.
Zoomer humor doesn't work on me.
Next.
Okay.
All right.
Um...
This game would be ended like an hour ago.
Not gonna lie.
If I didn't do all those bailouts.
I'm not done yet.
True?
All I'm saying is that we could end this game earlier.
I'm the only reason why I'm feeling so nice.
Because I keep doing bailouts.
I'm doing the tweet.
Nope.
All right.
You're out of the game, Philean.
Fine.
I mean, what else?
What else am I gonna do?
Philean.
Make the tweet your YouTube banner.
I'll bell you up.
I'm doing this tweet.
That's too honest.
No, make it your YouTube banner.
Make it your YouTube banner.
I don't know how to do that.
Don't lie.
You can't lie.
You damn well know.
I don't know how.
You're a liar.
Okay.
I don't know how.
Then you make a YouTube video recording yourself, reading
the tweet.
Okay.
What am I effing?
I can't make that joke.
Make it a short too.
Make it a short because she has more viewers than your
viewers.
Oh, basically I'm being sponsored.
I've been sponsored quite often.
Okay, I'll delete this joke.
Trick me, dude.
The most engagement is her shorts to geek it.
This will be her biggest short ever.
You'll make $3 on it.
Too late.
I made a decision.
Oh?
All right.
Time to bankrupt.
Press the button, Phyllian.
Any last offers?
It's over for you.
No.
No, we...
If Lumi even has an offer, she can't afford your bail.
I can't even fucking help you, man.
The only people can afford is me and Pippa.
All right, you burned the bridges.
Yeah, you burned all your bridges, Phyllian.
I knew I shouldn't have been PewDiePie.
What?
It's about down to our corporate.
All right, I hovered over it.
Put a precedent.
Let's try your cat girl while she's down.
It's put an honor, your honor.
I don't know what I'm saying.
So I just hit the button.
It's over.
Yeah, it says over.
Do it.
Yeah, I'm gonna hit it.
Unless you want to make that short.
Are you sure you want to make that short?
Yes, click yes.
Come on.
jury deleted the tweet anyway jury deleted it true true it's
over you're so close to freedom and i and i get to keep that
money nice oh shit oh shit all right i guess 130 dollars
from me let's roll that die she just robbed your corpse
philian how do you feel about that it was funny oh finally
the game can end
I can happily die now.
I'm good.
Chat, what's the point?
What's within the point of it all?
You gotta draw a card.
I haven't died in a factory on the cold floor.
You didn't have to.
You made your choice.
She gave you a deal.
You guys would not have made a YouTube short.
That's on you.
I would have made the short.
I would have made it.
You're not only gonna do what it takes.
Yeah, we'll see when you lose two if you're gonna make it.
Alright, I'll pay the 30 bucks.
That is 30.
Chad, this is why it's hard to make friends with B2B.
I'm happy to help a friend with me.
Let's go see your bail bonds.
We're gonna collab together.
Oh, not doubles.
I'm lucky.
I guess I'll stay in jail a little longer.
I guess I'll stay in jail a little bit longer.
So unfortunate.
Oh, Pippa.
Either I lose the PIP or a Philly or there's no...
That's your own property, so it's fine.
Yeah.
Should we twiddle?
I'm dead.
I'm dead in a couple turns.
Please, jail.
Please let me have jail time.
You guys made a cult.
You know, I'm muting myself to go cry.
I mean, talk to my chat.
I can still hear you.
I want to talk to my chat.
Yay, money!
I should...
Oh, you know what?
I'm going to go build a little bit.
I'm going to...
Okay, as long as I'm out last.
Oh, I can't wait, I can build.
Alright, let's build a little bit here.
Since I'm in jail, I can still do real estate.
You know?
I can still do real estate while I'm here.
That's the power of the jail system.
Yeah.
Alright, we'll put a house here.
And then we'll put a house here.
Good luck.
Uh-oh.
Good luck, Looney.
Good luck.
And then, I'm ready to roll my die.
Ooh.
Yeah.
It just works.
Oh my god.
Thanks, Todd.
Oh, no.
Oh, I guess I gotta pay a fine on my own.
Oh, I'm on my own property.
Hey there, guys.
Hey.
This is so illegal.
Don't get owes you a free railroad fare.
I'm hungry, man.
Come on, dude.
Just kill me.
Don't be taking out bags.
Shoot me in the fucking head.
You guys are all just surviving right now.
But that they got none of it.
Take me out back, man.
I can model crap.
Just declare bankruptcy now.
This cruel world.
Just declare bankruptcy.
That's all you have to do.
Please, please, please.
Come on.
Free parking, free parking, free parking, free parking.
Free parking.
Where's that?
What is it?
That's me.
That's green.
That's the house I just built.
Goodbye.
You have to have to go.
I don't think I can even afford with mortgage.
She can't afford it even with a mortgage.
I literally can't, I can't afford anything.
Goodbye, homie.
I literally can't fucking afford shit.
It was a good run, boys.
Billy had moved over in the cock chair.
I'm coming, okay?
Well, I mean, then you won't even need to be in the cock
chair.
Like, we can, we, okay, yeah, yeah, true, true, true.
All right.
It's bankrupt time.
At least I'm on my last face.
All right.
Leroy Jenkins.
I mean, with all those bailouts, it'd be pretty
embarrassing, B.
That's crazy!
Wait, Doki just gets my properties?
Yeah, because you couldn't pay off, so I take your property.
Yeah, I wouldn't know.
Ask me anything.
Alright, Pippa, what you got?
Look at that.
There's me.
Wait, so you have everything some little yellow.
Wait, Pippa, do you have any more yellow?
Does everything have some yellow?
I could get on yellow and then I'd lose.
Wait, no, I can mortgage.
You want, like, $5.
I can mortgage, though.
The brown isn't worth anything.
Yeah, it's not worth much.
Brown isn't worth anything.
She's surviving by, like, the...
Yeah, $4.
End of my teeth.
Friends of benefits.
All right, here you go.
I might get the yellow, though.
You got this.
All you got to do is bankrupt her.
Fuck.
Do I go to jail again?
Pippa, you're the last one to jail again.
I know, it's like, it was funny if I go to jail again.
Yay!
Capipulism is this.
this property okay where are you gonna go here i could put
it on here on the reds yeah i hear boss music all right here
i'm gonna put one here here and here oh wait no i don't want
to learn you have to eventually land here sometime right you
only want could you cheat when pippa dc to the start i said
it you know what true yeah okay to be fair though well each
one of us cheated in some way in this Monopoly game.
We live in a society.
What is it?
I cheat!
What the fuck?
Oh shit, I knew I knew I'd be investing in that one.
I knew I calculated it!
Oh my god, perfect calculations!
Oh god.
Hey, you can make it to jail.
Yeah, you can still go to jail.
I'm not making it to jail.
You can almost get there.
Wait, $7, $7.
I didn't write this.
It just happened to me.
Yeah!
$70!
Oh my god.
Yeah, I can still land on yellow.
No, I can't.
Yeah, and he's tired of laughing around the board later.
It's okay, Timma, you got this.
Why?
I don't want you throwing me on.
Oh, hey, 200.
I want you to win because she just doesn't want me to win.
It just doesn't want me to win.
Alright, let's see.
Where are you gonna head to next?
Oh, fuck.
Jesus.
She's like an actual murderer.
You're gonna die regardless when you land on the red here.
I'm gonna...
Oh no, not the millionaires.
How many more millionaires must fall?
Those fucking poor millionaires.
I'm with you, Pippa.
Alright, Pippa, you got this!
Come on, grab your pitchboard!
Say a pitchboard before you roll.
I believe.
Oh, boardwalk.
Save scum or is it boardwalks I think that's I think it's
GG's No, I think that's a seven No, there's three rounds
That's the one that did me it Yeah You can mortgage You can
mortgage You can mortgage It might be Joven Oh no, I might
be Joven You can You're still at home It's all meant no
effect of me getting killed No Oh, God.
All right, Pippa, what are you gonna do?
What are you gonna do?
You can't...
You have to sell each house.
There's a one more three, so you have to sell that.
And then you gotta sell.
And then you gotta keep selling.
Oh, it hurts to watch.
And then you have to sell the other one.
Oh, it hurts to watch some...
Oh, Pippa, no.
You're almost there.
It's okay.
One more house.
Yeah!
Yeah, you can afford it now.
I think it's $7.50.
Oh, you can't.
Sorry.
I lied.
I forgot how...
Now you can afford it.
It's been an honor serving with you, Pippa.
She's still alive!
Look, damn it!
It's like I can still get into jail.
You can still get into jail.
Don't worry.
Yay!
Oh my god.
Seven, where's that?
Oh hey, there's chance.
Maybe I can get to jail.
Yeah, I could just click out of the game.
If I just tab out of the game, no one will.
Oh!
Yay!
You have to go to jail!
It's a living honor in one house.
Where is she going next?
I'm wondering, Your Honor.
Let her go!
Where is she going next, though?
Oh, it's all right.
Okay, here we go.
We're gonna put a green here.
And then also here.
Bro, she's buying houses from jail!
Oh!
She's like, she's on the Joker, bro.
She's so cold with shots.
I called out to you.
It's rich person jail.
Okay, guys.
You can lie in jail, too.
Oh, the society.
Oh, she's one spot away from jail.
Oh, hey, I just bought houses there, too.
What a coincidence.
You hear that?
The police are coming.
Can you afford?
Wait, mortgage everything.
You can still mortgage everything.
You can mortgage everything.
Yeah.
See?
You can afford it now.
Hang on for dear life, Fibba.
There you go.
Is that...
Fuck.
You need to mortgage one more.
This is so grim.
There you go.
Oh, fuck no.
I don't think you can afford it.
You get one more.
She's only one more mortgage.
And then she can.
Oh, brother.
There you go.
Come on.
That last mortgage is looking at you.
You gotta mortgage it.
You gotta also train with Doki.
I can't even afford her.
I can't even afford it.
Oh, my God.
Time to turn.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm in jail.
How could this happen to me?
This is your rocky arc.
Don't worry.
How could I be in jail?
Oh, it's so unfortunate.
I can't even leave jail.
Oh, man.
is she gonna go next oh my god boardwalk okay you know what
that's where it all ends okay okay i know like you can't
afford boardwalk so i'm just gonna put houses on here
you can fit three on the clock chair i'm I'm fighting gloomy
in the Gogog right now, Pippa.
Oh, you got saved!
Oh my god!
You got saved!
By the luxury tax!
Oh my god.
Oh my fucking god.
How about that?
Wow, I feel good.
You're gonna cross the drain.
You're gonna cross clear bankruptcy.
Pippa!
You can't lose right now.
You can't just give up.
You're so good, Pippa, don't worry.
I'm rubbing your shoulders.
You're still in this fight, Pippa.
One more Don't touch me with your loser hand.
Maybe that's why.
Oh, hey.
That's the one I just put your house on.
It's okay.
It's not worth anything.
Yeah, it's just $20.
You have an epic holiday in right now.
You're good.
Yeah, you're good.
The cockroach is playing right there.
Wee.
Oh, I don't have it.
It's okay.
I gotta get a jail free card.
Oh.
That's my place.
Isn't it?
Oh, it is.
Hey there.
Why is it so hard, huh?
It's alright.
She still has, like, a long way to go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
For sure, for sure.
We got this.
I believe in you.
Wait, Pivot.
We need to negotiate.
Part of the deal.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
You can afford to un-mortgage?
All you gotta do is...
It would be a shame if you landed on my place again Yeah
Yeah It would be such a shame It would suck Wow Hey you get
to visit jail Skin of your teeth right now Now that
literally not touching me anymore Oh my god You get to visit
where I was It's like a tourist destination now The famous
dokeybird was in that jail
You can buy souvenirs for like $75.
You can still spend $150.
This.
You should mortgage it.
Okay, I'm going to need you to roll too.
You can buy hers.
Her souvenirs.
Good luck with like two sides of this board.
Wait.
Yeah, that's fine.
You're fine.
Don't worry about it.
You're so fine.
You're fine.
Don't worry about it.
You're going to be okay, people.
What's the worst that can happen on the community chest?
Wait, how much does it cost us?
It's like only 130, so like it's fine.
It's like...
You're about to Morgan.
A boy was an old thing.
She's calculating right now.
Yeah!
That whole time she gets $24 from me.
That $24 is gonna be so much.
Yeah, she's gonna leave!
Goodbye.
He's the mortgage!
Yeah, if you mortgage, you can afford it!
If you mortgage, you can afford it!
Oh my god.
If you land on this face, I'm gonna jump.
Thank you.
That'll be so funny.
Chad, it's not over till the last man sings.
You're still in this.
Yeah, you're still in this.
Yeah?
Do I land on your space again?
That's your own space, right?
Yeah, see?
Oh yeah!
It's your area!
You still need this!
Look at that!
Oh my god!
You're still here!
I think she actually...
No, no, no, she's not here.
I just missed it.
I landed on my longest waterworks.
Oh no!
Yay!
Come on, Pippa!
You're still in it!
Pippa, you can go to Jade.
if you're real lucky.
Yeah, but she's not lucky.
Okay, now it's over.
Now it's over.
Say it ain't so.
Yucky, we can make a deal.
Give me all yellow properties.
What?
Give me all your yellow properties.
Stop.
She's already dead, Your honor.
Your dignity.
Hold your ears up high, Fibba.
I want all I want all your yellows Change your YouTube
banner, Fibba I want all your yellows If you want to keep
going I want all your yellows Make a TikTok, Fibba Alright,
no, this is gonna work out Alright, she's gonna land She's
gonna land on all of like the luxury taxes Alright, how much
do you need?
How much does she need?
How much was it?
Give me a hundred Why are you cooking one at a time?
No, it was 100.
Not 200.
You already told me.
No, it was 200.
You already told me how much it was.
I told you we can talk about this!
I can't talk about this!
Not even the 199!
Are you kidding me?
Riz.
Accept the deal.
Accept it.
Everyone lose my dignity.
Accept.
No!
She bent the knee.
Good deal.
Oh my god.
I'll pay.
Are you gonna buy back the Morgan after doing this to her?
No.
I'll pay back the Morgan.
She'll be fine.
Oh my god.
I can afford it.
At least let it be close.
Stop!
I want to pay for it.
So painful.
Thank you.
You're so painful to watch.
You're still in for it.
You're still in it.
You after this Like you're still in it I have no property
talking You're just gonna stare in your eyes You perish
Welcome to my house Oh no It's okay baby you're gonna hit go
You're gonna land on go Yeah I'm okay You're gonna go on the
boardwalk You're gonna go on the boardwalk You're gonna land
on Boardwalk There's a property place for life You're going
to Paris.
No, kid.
We actually have nothing I want.
No, I didn't.
No, no, no.
We end on boardwalk.
It's a beautiful death, Pippa.
Watch the stuff.
Declare bankruptcy right now.
All the full, all the full.
And I just want to say this is silly insult.
It shouldn't go.
As a prophet.
We end on boardwalk!
Chad, I wasn't saying boardwalk when I rolled to get it.
I was saying because I was predicting what it would end.
That was a callback.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh, my God.
Monopoly is pretty easy, guys.
Holy shit.
No, yeah, you have a fun time.
Yeah, I actually got it.
Nobody wins.
So we had a great time, everyone.
I had a great time, guys.
Yeah, we have cucumber sandwiches for refreshments.
Remember my pride just eat straight away from my head, don't
you?
It's okay.
I rehired all you guys to work for me
Now you all you work for me now.
All right Okay, can we talk about something?
Yeah, I'm really sorry for flaming you guys
and i want to make a peace offering i want to make a peace
offering yeah what is it yeah okay you got to talk for a
minute i'll i'll go put it together okay give me one sec you
guys a peace offering i'll make a peace offering i'm kind of
scared me too here no i'll just i think give me a minute
okay i'm scared what is she gonna do i'll be back i'll be
back i'll be back i'll be back where's she gonna do it guys
i don't trust her i don't trust her either yeah i don't
trust still blippy remember when she rigged the game yeah
remember that she deleted the tweet yeah remember when we
made a deal and then she like deleted the tweet fucking went
back yeah i did like okay that's scummy behavior yeah like
the one person that i'm gonna remember this for the next
vtuber oh yeah heading into my call out post i'm writing the
twill longer fillion among your other crimes don't get us
doesn't care about the award she's asking you for one one
already It's not my fault.
I know business.
Okay.
I'm still going.
Yeah.
All right.
What are you doing?
I'm making a peace offering.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Okay.
Sounds good.
We're waiting.
Okay.
You have to wait like a minute and a half.
I'm like, I'm drawing.
It's like...
You're taking a really long time.
There's dead air.
It's like...
You're ruining our stream.
Do you guys see something?
care about stream our stream content do you not care about
us i'm trying are you trying to sabotage our streams what's
your favorite color that's the content we're here
do a flip fill in yeah do a fill i'm drawing dude what flip
while you're trying called mask too okay i'll let me do
balance a plate on your head too yes watch here what is this
like this here oh oh where did you grab a plate where did it
oh hey it wasn't glass we didn't hear it shatter it wasn't
true i feel like i was stolen from robbed skamaz yeah all
right pippo i'm not very satisfied what do we want to talk
about on yelp what should we talk about how much how much
balloons are filliness do you know i think filly is just
really bad at board I think, you know, like, the V-Foomber
Award is, like, the only, like, sense of control she can
have in her life, you know?
That's why it's great.
Wow!
I think the saddest part is that she organized this collab
and she got knocked out for this.
That is pretty sad.
You know, like, if you told me she threw for content, I
wouldn't believe you.
Guys, if you guys want to watch winners...
No, no, no, I have an offering, I have an offering, I have
an offering, I have an offering.
Yeah?
check this all right check discord yeah there what is this
she the fuck is that what the fuck is that that's a house my
last property olive brobs olive brobs i know the type but
it's my last property and i just want to say doki you
deserve it okay i grew up in this area it was my five nights
at freddies but i bestowed this is the bit this is what you
made us wait for this is it no uh i feel like i should get
paid to even see this like I feel like you should pay me to
even look at this.
Time is money, Philly.
This is my business venture.
If you guys put in $5,000 each, I'll give you 1% company.
To be fair.
This is our exit plan from streaming, man.
Like five years.
When we're old and no one gives a frick anymore, what are we
going to have?
I rather like...
This is your Amaranth gas station.
Oh, Bramps.
Okay, to be fair, like after what we saw, how you we saw you
conduct business i don't think i want to invest in anything
that you offer okay how about you okay okay then short my
stock nerd short my stock nerd see what happens game stop of
the epic game chat i just don't like the stock philian i
don't know what to say i just don't know then short me then
short me i just don't like the stock you're no game i don't
think they'll let you i don't think they'll allow you to be
on the stock market because how we need more than like three
steps into the stock market and phase is not being that but
i am I don't think you're allowed to be on the stock market.
It's gonna be I don't think so Okay, okay, here's my plan.
I walk up with a Glock right and I say it's fake All right,
that was a great stream everybody I had a great time with
everyone playing and everybody had I had a great time
winning Monopoly guys No, I changed my mind.
I didn't have a great time
you're all beautiful you're all wait what was the word you
just said we're all beautiful no wait what lumi said ladies
ladies nuts on your face shut the fuck up phillian phillian
fucking sore loser okay everybody ggs great time meeting you
guys it's a great time meeting me and pippa yeah nice
meeting
Thank you so much.
It's no problem.
Thank you for inviting me.
And thank you to Phelion for setting this collab up.
At this point, I think she's into this, you know, like into
like the whole, like I think she's an M at that point, you
know?
She's a huge M.
Why is an M?
No, I'm an M.
She's clearly a huge M.
I'm an F.
Because she like, you know, she invited all three of us to
like just rag on her.
And like, honestly, she's 100% an M at that point.
I am an M.
for this yeah i'm a woman billion if you say oink oink we'll
give you the 5 000 to buy your stock no i'm waiting so at
least she gets like she gets 2 500.
you get half of it good job good job yeah i just gotta give
it 50 idiot can you do like a pig 3d model let's play this
again if you lose again can we do like let's do this again
if i lose i'll make it a big made outfit and then i'll wear
it yeah but then you want that though you like that that
doesn't you're in you made it to embarrassing we need to
tell me something you actually don't want to do okay that i
don't want to be in a not in a main outfit that's it so
there i won't wear a main outfit i won't wear a main outfit
hey jeez everybody jeez jeez i'm going to talk to my chat
now had a great time bye guys
wow that stream could have ended like an hour ago if i
didn't prolong it for so long
guys sorry i i know i have a second stream today but like i
just did it i just wanted somebody to lose first
look i just i'm just saying look i know we could have ended
we could have like let them go from their misery but like i
just wanted a specific person to lose first um I did not
expect to win Monopoly, not gonna lie.
I haven't played Monopoly in so long, but like, it's
actually pretty funny when I can, I was like, you know, what
was that word?
When you put your foot in a door, where you negotiate for
something much higher than what you actually want, and they
actually did that, did that, and I was like, guys, that's
basic business 101.
What the fuck?
great i had a great time um i agree time i guess like
winning is always a good time so that's why i had
i always have a good time winning you know it's always a
blast uh but yeah um we do have a second stream we do have a
second stream tonight with follow i'm gonna uh i'm gonna
push the stream uh up by 15 minutes just so i can like chill
a little bit because i didn't realized I'd play like three
plus hours of Monopoly.
Also guys I literally okay it was so funny because like I
told I I want to be like I told you so because like I I told
them about like yeah like there's like online issues with
Monopoly because I know like people had to in the past we
would have I remember like people like to get around with it
like someone would like screen share or something or like I
don't remember I don't think I've done remote play before
but I don't haven't of others they would like screen share
monopoly and then like um and then like they'll like say
what move they want to do and then they'll do the moves and
stuff like that so like i knew there was that option and
then there was like remote play so i was like guys i think
we gotta like don't use online feature because there's a
huge online issue and i like brought that up like like two
to three i think like three times and then we went in i was
like guys i told i told you guys
I was like I told you guys there's online issues I don't
know I think the funniest part is that Phyllian literally
forgot the time that she set up because I was like me, Pippa
and Lumi were watching the stream and then like we saw her
on like Bunny Girl and then we saw her like she was like why
are they 30 minutes early like what the fuck is going on
like what's wrong with them and then i had to i copied and
paste the exact time she told us to show up and it was like
2 30.
so me pipa lumi were just sitting here waiting and be like
guys what i thought guys are we supposed to start i was like
i was supposed to start so we got confused too I don't know.
We're like, did we get the time right?
And then we need to set up as well.
Uh.
But yeah.
There was fun time winning the game.
Anyway, guys.
Uh, I love to talk more.
But we do have a second stream.
So I'll talk more in the second stream chat.
Um, I'll see you guys there for a part two.
Uh, father four!
Yeah!
Anyway, guys, I am going to raid my own channel.
I'll see you guys there, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.